there's this big story that's going uh
it's been going around for a little bit
people have been talking about for some
weeks it's that houses are becoming
impossible to buy but there's something
strange about the story and without
getting a bit too conspiratorial one
fact is that Pension funds and Wall
Street and big investment firms with
International interests are buying up
houses at massive price massive uh
amounts above cost somebody will say hey
I'm going to sell my house for you know
200k and they'll be like we'll give you
250. pricing out any middle class person
from the market
houses it's it's a very direct and
simple way that middle class people
transfer wealth to their kids you buy a
house you get old you die your kids
inherit that house
now it's going to be the middle class or
permanent renters because all these big
firms are buying up houses like crazy
and maybe there's just maybe it's a good
money making opportunity for these
Federal reserve-backed institutions but
at the same time we're getting these
stories where they're saying Millennials
regret buying their houses and middle
class people don't want to buy houses
anymore and I'm like why is why are
there all these articles coming out
claiming people don't want to own houses
at the same time the biggest investment
firms are buying houses that just seems
kind of odd to me at the very least it's
going to result in middle class people
not owning property not owning wealth
squandering what little wealth they have
inadvertently and massive Wall Street
companies or you know whatever owning
everything
some people are saying all right this is
just part of the Great reset you will
own nothing and you will be happy 10
years from now 20 years from now the
Next Generation they won't have things
there's a lot to go through we'll break
this down plus a bunch of other stories
there's apparently a story come out
saying they weren't even selling bats
the Wuhan wet Market Anthony fauci says
I am science and got really mad on TV so
joining us today is we got Jack sobit
hey hey Jack so big senior editor human
events welcome back author of the new
book antifa stories inside the backpack
go to antifa book.com and check it out
filling in for Jack Murphy I know a lot
of people were expecting another Jack
this evening uh Jack couldn't be here
today and asked me to cover for him as
the official Wednesday Jacks yeah you
got but you got to do it in the official
like anchor like Jack Murphy has the
night off I will be filling in ladies
and gentlemen tonight Jack Murphy has
the night off I will be playing the role
of Jack Murphy though with a slightly
less conspicuous beard we got Sheamus
got Sheamus over here we don't have the
Illinois boys tonight unfortunately but
I'm happy to sit here with the other
Jack I will and we will be pouring out
an old style for our fallen brother an
old style that's right Ian's chilling
with the electro plasma ball someone
asked in the in the chat asking you
shall receive there you go like why
isn't Ian sitting at the plasma ball
electricity so they said that in the
chat before they could see Ian yeah
we're talking about Collective memory is
this room bugged something I remember
they were asking that he'd do it they
asked they were like can we have Ian sit
by the plasma ball makes him look cool
he was already here I'm not doing it
because you asked dude I want to they're
watching we got Lydia I am also here in
the corner pushing buttons for these
guys I request that they not argue with
each other too much but we'll see what
happens can we argue with you yeah
we'll we'll just argue with a straw man
of the left we'll pretend like there's a
left only the worst arguments possible
I'll be the strongest yeah yeah
our internet got struck by lightning
and we I guess one of the one of the
boxes downstairs like one of our Network
boxes got Fried by it so we're you know
I think it's working I don't know if the
internet cuts out I was watching uh I
was watching Loki earlier and I just
shut off and I was so mad oh man it's
like I'm in the middle of watching Loki
man so that wasn't like Thor doing like
a whole life he's like I don't want you
watching this
yeah
never again well let's let's uh we'll
get serious before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member by
clicking that big old members only
button and then you will get access to
the exclusive members only area I can
only assume that tonight's members only
exclusive will be a hoot because we got
the Jack Sheamus me Ian Lydia
everybody's here so it'll be a a loud
and raucous conversation I suppose
talking about the things that YouTube
typically doesn't want us to talk about
yeah and when you become a member you
don't just get these amazing segments
which you don't want to miss you're
actually helping fund the expansion of
our mission so we've got a newsroom
launching hopefully in the next week or
two I don't have an exact date yet it's
going to be particularly rudimentary to
start but we're going to start bringing
on journalists immediately and expanding
and expanding expanding and then we're
going to have our own news Operation
fact checking these lying fake news
journalists and put not the real news
and it's going to be very very precise
and academic and we are going to have
like one of the most rigorous fact
checking operations we're actually
trying to get another so we're gonna
we're gonna hire fact Checkers then
we're going to hire a fact Checker to
fact check us and have them somewhere
like 20 miles away so they never
interact with anyone here and they read
the articles go through them and we do
that to to uh try and filter framing
properly so if everyone's hanging out
and talking about everything and they're
like that's Joe Biden admitting he's a
liar then someone 20 miles away doesn't
talk to us hears and says I don't think
he's saying he's a liar I think he's
saying this and then we can also try and
make sure we're doing proper Framing and
stuff so become a member let's talk
about this tweet from Jack besobic
this guy Jack busovic antifa book.com
he's got he's got some nerve he said
this should be this should be illegal in
all 50 states and punishable by federal
prison time was he referring to it's a
Twitter thread where cultural husbandry
uh notes BlackRock is buying every
single family house they can find paying
20 to 50 percent above asking price and
outbidding normal home buyers why are
corporations Pension funds and property
Investments groups buying entire
neighborhoods
well it goes on to say it's basically
the great reset the middle class uses
homeownership land ownership to transfer
wealth to their children but what
happens when during a great reset or I'm
sorry during a pandemic there's a great
reset as it were of people's jobs of
businesses everybody gets knocked out of
the playing field sort of levels a lot
of people out their businesses are
closed family businesses these are some
of the most horrifying stories companies
that have been around for like 100 Years
Gone overnight now these people are
going to become renters many moved they
want to buy houses it's not that hard to
buy a house people think it is but all
of a sudden you find us how you're on
zillow.com and you're flicking and
you're like man this is so cool look at
this house and then you call the agent
and he says oof just sold for 50k above
asking you're like how am I supposed to
compete with that as a regular person
how are millennials supposed to build
wealth when these companies are coming
in and buying a Ball's property yeah I
mean they're not I wish that that Jack
follow were here so we could have a
conversation with him on his perspective
on the matter but I think that what is
happening is is terrible I'm generally a
fan of the free market but part of why
this was possible was because the
government came down and they shut down
the or the government came in they shut
down the entire economy for months and
then they also printed a bunch of money
inflating the dollar and so for your
average person given the savings they
had prior it's going to be much more
difficult for them to afford a house in
these massive companies are going to be
able to so it's a consolidation of
wealth the likes of which I predicted
would occur
as a result of this bailout and as a
result of the shutdown and it has and
the fact is people who don't own
property are much easier to control and
check this out you can't even build a
house now so this was reported back in
April it's about 40 Grand more to build
a house today because of the
skyrocketing Lumber and steel prices
which have only gone higher so imagine
this it's it's July of last year you got
a few thousand dollars in savings and
you're like I got enough to put down on
buying a house not anymore you don't
maybe you were like okay I saved up
enough to actually get a loan for a new
construction not anymore you don't that
new concert is way too expensive so what
happens not only that not only has it
become harder because of inflation and
skyrocketing materials prices you
finally are like well I have enough I've
saved enough I've overcome these these
challenges and then sorry BlackRock
outbid You by 25 yeah and you know going
off so Jack is here and turns out the
guy is here
um yeah this you're absolutely right
though this was a situation where the
government said you see Fannie Mae
deciding to want to do this to say look
all of these people went underwater in
their you know they we called it
remember the toxic subprime loans and
the mortgages and people were buying
houses they couldn't afford et cetera
Etc okay we know how that started we
know who the people were responsible for
it but we live in this strange system
where the same people who are called
upon to fix it are actually the ones who
created the problem in the first place
and then how it goes so who do they turn
to oh that you know themselves who could
solve this problem we can we'll buy it
ourselves and then and the one that he
actually doesn't mention in the thread
but I would throw out there that it's
and it's just absolutely huge and you
see so many wealthy Chinese families
coming in Chinese Elites CCP Elites that
know that their money is if it's in a
Chinese bank and you've run a foul of
the party if you become the new persona
on grata right Xi Jinping or whoever it
is in the politburo can reach right in
and snag that from you they're using it
as tax Havens they're using attack
shelters they're getting out of it and
they know by the way that the market is
just super hot right now so it actually
is in a financial sense a very fantastic
investment but it's the financialization
of what is supposed to be and has
traditionally been this wealth ownership
this wealth generation for middle class
for working class families that now is
being completely turned into the next
Commodities Market you don't have
landlords anymore you've got some guy
who's owning it on Wall Street they've
set up like a front company to manage
the whole thing right so it's not like
you know it's not like one guy oh I
flipped a couple of houses and now I've
got like 10. I had a cousin who had you
know he had 10 houses in the
Indianapolis area so he's he's running
it himself basically and maybe has a
couple people working for him but it's
not that anymore yeah doesn't you know
call centers and and and you know
mechanics that are all aren't there a
bunch of Chinese like you mentioned
Chinese wealthy people but isn't like
large swaths of land in the west just
like open acreage bought by wealthy
Chinese families and farmland too yeah
environment yeah absolutely and this is
there's a ton of stuff that they're
putting in because people understand
that you know when you say CCP in China
you know it you know people have this
tendency and it makes sense that you
want to put that into Amer an American
perspective right we we categorize
things by trying to put into boxes that
are familiar to us but there isn't
anything like the CCP in the United
States because it's well they say well
you know their government stops here and
their business starts there so that's
that's the separation no there is no
separation there's no real separation
and these these aren't necessarily sort
of like nefarious plots right this is
just a general strategy that they're
employing they say real they realize
that if they own this Farmland then they
can control U.S output they can get
better consumption for uh Chinese Goods
obviously their consumption of this is
going to be much more than us they know
that in many cases when they were
fighting back against these tariffs that
President Trump was was employing when
he first got in Joe Biden by the way has
kept a lot of these tariffs in place
because they they're widely popular
they're extremely popular and they know
though that the farmers of the US are
doing a lot of sales on the
international market a lot of that ends
up in China they can kind of set the
prices on this but they realize hey if
we own the land then we can just control
the Farms directly do you know who the
who the largest private Farmland owners
in the United States is
the one where it's Bill Gates it's Bill
Gates Bill Gates is the largest private
Farmland owner in the U.S good for him
yeah regarding rolling the sleeves up
I'm glad something could finally happen
for that guy
hold on let me sorry there's more the
gates aren't the only one percenters
with dirt in their portfolios over the
last decade Farmland has taken off as an
asset class Finance speak for a type of
investment That Wall Street sales people
urge wealthy people to include in their
well-bounced portfolios the basic pitch
by land they aren't making it anymore so
it's not just Bill Gates I mean there's
a lot of conspiracies about why he's
doing it and I think he just wants to
own land I think owning land is a really
smart investment that's what they say to
people buy land the point is the
billionaires are buying it up they're
also buying a Bitcoin I don't think they
expect to lose money on these things but
when Working Class People middle class
people can't buy these things they can't
buy Bitcoin I'm not saying they should
you know don't get advice from me but if
they can't buy land then what can they
transfer to their to their kids what
will they own a desire for land this is
what's scary and sort of um I want to
jump back to part of the discussion on
real estate but I will say this as well
I know that earlier this year China was
buying so much they were buying up so
many of the Corn Futures there's so much
corn Futures that they ended up pushing
the market to an eight-year high so they
see yeah so they seem to be very
interested in this
um I know also that with these massive
companies purchasing real estate
part of what frightens me about that I
mentioned this earlier when I said that
people who don't own property are easier
to control is that we have seen payment
processors and credit card companies in
the past decline service to people who
they disagree with politically or who
are very controversial who's to say that
these massive companies don't get woke
take a stand and say we're not going to
rent to bigots wow it's almost like
Bitcoin solves a lot of those who if
regarding the Chinese uh purchase of
land so if if a Chinese citizen bought
land the CCP could seize that land from
that Chinese person because they're
Chinese citizen is that right not easily
right but they could they you know they
could but it more likely than not have
been put in some kind of arbitrary let's
say if it's if it's a jail or something
if it's American land they would have to
do it through the person right the
Chinese government's not going to come
to the United States government here
like that legal document that says that
person owns it we own it now we're gonna
be like get out of here but they could
station Chinese troops on that piece of
land like okay if if a Chinese citizen
buys a piece of land in the United
States does the United States still own
the land like how does that work who
owns that property
China can't put troops there no they
can't do that what obviously think about
spies what about like private they can
put spy surreptitiously but that's your
private security yes they could hire and
station Private Security in Chinese and
those private security have to operate
under U.S laws until the war breaks out
they can do the things you would do on
your road before the war breaks the US
military goes in and sweeps it out like
yeah but how much land do they own
that's my concern if they're buying up
if if War breaks out they don't own any
land that's the best part but if all of
the debt that China holds in the U.S if
right now just like you know Joe Biden's
sitting there and he just like he's like
falling asleep and then he falls oh I
declare war on China oh what happened
our death's gone there's no debt when
you're at War imagine being like imagine
some guy being like you owe me a hundred
bucks and then he and then punching him
in the face
anymore you're fighting my concern is if
they buy up thousands of farms and then
station private security all over the
place Chinese private security and then
that's just an Insurgent Insurance well
I mean the goal the goal is financial
directly right and this is something
where you know and I've had large
disagreements with people on this this
very question over you know are we
falling into you know the the thucydides
Trap right is it is there an un is there
an uh impossible to get away from war
with China that we are hurtling towards
is this inevitable is this something
that cannot be stopped and I look the
way I look at it is I I think something
more like the great reset is is more
like what's inevitable because China
doesn't want to go to war with us we're
their biggest customer right they want
us to be in that consumer mode they want
us to be in that constant state of like
you said not not owning property not
worrying about you know trying to
generate wealth of our own as long as
it's enough where we're purchasing their
goods we're not causing any problems
we're not getting involved too much with
the real you know the actual realities
on the ground is the way things
um you know are in China you know don't
worry about those uyghurs you know don't
worry about those people in Hong Kong
don't worry about the freedom Fighters
that are you know constantly being
detained throughout China we just saw
the uh this huge protest in Nanjing
University right into Normal University
which might seem kind of insignificant
as a university protest whatever
um you know we have those in the U.S
what like every five minutes in China
that's a big deal in China that's quite
a big deal there are workers protests in
China in the provinces on a fairly
regular basis but they're just not heard
about in in U.S media they don't have
social media access we don't know about
it a lot but it's it's a constant I
think this in in the mid 2000s is going
on a lot but for students to protest
like that I mean you know and obviously
we're in very close proximity to the uh
the anniversary of Tiananmen Square and
nowhere near on that scale right because
Tiananmen wasn't even just Beijing all
over the country but to see any uh
Chinese students at you know kids in
their 20s basically standing up against
the the government because essentially I
don't know the story The the idea was
they have been going to what were
considered private universities but the
Ministry of Education had come in and
said yeah you're not going to be private
any user adversities anymore we're going
to consolidate you down we're going to
consider you these to be vocational Tech
schools at this point so it's basically
kind of like like imagine if you had
spent all the money to go to a private
university and then you know the
government comes in and says yeah that's
a community college now so you know
you're calling your you know your degree
is worth it was worth here and now it's
worth here and in China that's still a
huge huge deal so the kids go nuts they
know absolutely nuts and the police came
in and were just completely brutal with
them but the difference is this went
super viral all across Chinese media
what the recently so last week oh yeah
and they like locked the city down
didn't they uh yeah the whole city got
put under lockdown
um it was multiple campuses where this
thing broke out at one point the the
Chinese government came out and the CCP
saying oh well they took the dean
hostage right and so that's why we had
to go in right and I was and I don't
yeah you wonder if they were actually
taking kind of like a black lives matter
sort of take on things but then the kids
posted pictures of the guy and he had he
had like a box of chicken and a soda and
he said no he came and sat down with us
and you could see like other kids
sitting around with them and so yeah
yeah I know what you're saying Evergreen
it's kind of hard to tell but it didn't
look like a hostage I mean at Evergreen
College they definitely you know locked
the administrators and they're like we
didn't hold anybody hostage like they
weren't free to leave though but so so
in in terms of we're talking about the
potential for war for war with China we
have the story from Yahoo so much at
stake PM's chilling warning on conflict
with China it's prime minister Scott
Morrison will he will call him the world
leaders to stand in unison against the
growing threat of China on Wednesday he
will deliver a major foreign policy
speech out of a trip to the United
Kingdom where he'll be a guest at a
meeting of the world economic Powers
including the US Germany and France bro
it sounds like war with China is
seriously on the horizon it's not just
this not just Australia being like yo
it's it's happening I mean obviously
China came back and they're like Ah
that's that's rubbish there's no war the
U.S just dispatched its Pacific Fleet
across the Pacific in anticipation of
Chinese Rockets
well right but so they initially so the
U.S has has their air fleet in two
different bases one in Japan I think in
Okinawa could be wrong and one in Guam
and there was concern that you're
talking about the aircraft or the Navy
uh it's the Air Force it's the Air Force
yes so they were worried that these
Chinese Rockets would just wipe out
these bases instantly they have no time
no time to scramble it wouldn't just be
the the basis be the entire Island I
mean right I've gone through those
scenarios when I was the Navy and I mean
it basically comes down to like at what
time would they be destroying what
facility right okay I was right there so
but but so what the US has done is
they've dispatched the fleet around the
Pacific so now there's like some bombs
here some planes there and they straight
up said oh it's so you know in
anticipation of war with China we will
not be vulnerable to these attacks we're
seeing that we're all seeing the
Pentagon is buying up weapons
specifically for Naval and Pacific
Warfare as opposed to Middle Eastern
Warfare like drone strikes and things
like that
seems like the city's trap is a is a
given and they recognize it now maybe
the economic stuff was an attempt to
stop it maybe this like NBA stuff was
like the more business we build up the
less likely there will be a war and War
was bad
sounds like war is going to happen yeah
so I I put it this way that if is there
a near-peer competitor that would be at
the most when I say that I mean another
state actor which would have a
comparable military to the United States
that the U.S could potentially go to
work number one definitely be China 100
right the reason that I'm still you know
I'd bet against it it's like I'd put it
60 40 right now is is because they're
just making so much money off of us
right they're constantly making money
off of us they're making even more money
now after the pandemic which they
certainly played to their own you know
I'm not one of those people who thinks
the pandemic was the you know a
deliberate plot or anything like that by
them but I think it's something that
once once it hit they realized how to
spend everything in their favor
financially speaking
um they're positioning themselves to be
the the major beneficiaries of the great
reset they're still in bed with all of
our elites with all the Western Elites
and and by and large have been financed
and built up by Western Elites
so here's right they're essentially
winning so why would they you know why
why go why we go hot right why shoot and
the only thing that I think that could
potentially lead to that is if you see
the actual party from the inside be
threatened if you see Xi Jinping uh feel
that his rule is threatened if you see
him uh potentially weakened and you know
by Rivals then maybe does he make a play
for Taiwan maybe there's a bunch of
protests breaking out across the country
which could threaten to destabilize the
social order that's why I keep an eye on
it yeah well so so you're mentioning
this a moment ago uh in in the in the
earlier segment but uh just a minute ago
that these massive protests were
breaking out in all across China I mean
is that something you think could make
the Chinese Communist Party fear their
control over the country potentially but
that's going to lead to internal
crackdowns that wouldn't be something
that would you know they would want to
do some kind of like um you know
external big like Wag the Dog type
approach to anything and you know Xi
Jinping is starting to now get credit
for essentially not you know I wouldn't
say the return of Hong Kong but just the
control role of Hong Kong right they
they view this as a huge win and if you
look at those uh the 6-4 anniversary so
the anniversary attendance square is
June 4th and if you look at those images
out of Victoria Park in Hong Kong
downtown Hong Kong this has always been
the spot where since 1989 the people of
Hong Kong particularly young young
people particularly students would go
out every single June 4th night and hold
a candlelight vigil there in Victoria
Park and so there's these Montage photos
people have put up on the internet where
it shows that it's it's this huge thing
and it's every year and it sort of
became this sort of hybrid dual meaning
where it's it's in commemoration of
Tiananmen Square but it's also that hey
we we know you don't want us doing this
after 1997 the Handover that okay we're
part of Chinese sovereignty now under
Beijing but we are still going to do
this because we are Hong Kong and we are
free last year it was uh incredibly
diminished crowd all of a sudden you see
this like this huge Park but it's only
maybe like 50 percent capacity and then
this last year it's empty you're you are
going to see a lot of people and I think
you are in the United States moving from
libertarian to authoritarian very very
quickly with the uh
Nickelodeon thing where the drag queen
dancer is showing the the red salute the
Communist Fist and telling the kids to
this is a good thing look at this
they're like flashing on the screen and
uh just a lot of what's happening in
this country it's hyperpolarization
right so so on my main channel uh
anything with kids anything involving
right right you're tripping you are
tripping those that that's a primal Red
Line right but practical spiritual
everything yeah the story of the dad and
the mom in Texas fighting over custody
of the kid who was the mom said it was
trans the dance it wasn't I mean these
are these are serious issues I I covered
uh vaccine segregation on my main
Channel today because Democrats are
increasingly pushing what they what is
called vaccine segregation so there's
going to be a grand reopening of New
York City where 70 percent of the
tickets will go to people who are
vaccinated and then 30 to people who are
unvaccinated will go to special
segregated areas uh Madison Square
Garden is doing an event where you have
to be fully vaccinated so you have to
have your two full doses it has to be a
few weeks after or whatever then you can
get in whereas red states are doing the
exact opposite so I I bring this up just
uh to tie it into what we're talking
about with China and the expansion and
possible War China is extremely
authoritarian the authoritarian nature
is allowing them just
Iron Fist control of Hong Kong right no
more protests right the U.S is being
rocked and Shattered by protest so I
think what's going to happen is you're
going to see a lot of people who are
just I mean I've already heard the
conversations where they're like well
Freedom Is For Peace time you know
libertarianism Liberty is for peace time
when you're in a time of War that's when
the the rules go out the window you've
got the potential for war with China and
this is what a lot of people are saying
because we're such a free-spirited
country that allows a lot of Liberty it
allows the rise of subversive groups who
would weaken us at a time when we're
facing potential War China's not doing
that if China goes to war their
country's locked down and Everyone Falls
in line if the U.S goes to war it's just
gonna we're gonna well there's also a
huge uh dichotomy there as well
um you talked to uh you know we talked
about Millennials earlier right
um I don't know how many Millennials I'd
love to actually pull up the millennial
homeownership numbers well we all know
it's terrible we all know what to do
it's really bottomed out but how many of
how many Millennial homeowners are
flying you know American flags in front
of
right and and you know it's going to be
I don't know if there's any strategies
in this but my guess is that would be
quite quite a lot less than their
parents right in China it's the exact
opposite the the generation that you are
seeing come up now in China are 10 times
more hyper nationalistic than any that
has perceived them potentially since the
Communist you know uh the Communist
cultural revolution of the 1960s was
there like a noticeable change in the
Chinese population after Tiananmen
Square and because maybe you can explain
a little bit about I mean
it would be after the the great um the
one child policies when you see the
noticeable shift it's like a plateau
just drops off I part of part of me just
would love to see a simulation of what
these leftists would experience should
China win the economic war and and any
potential hot conflict can we send them
there yeah it's it's not it's it's but
but they wouldn't leave every bideswalk
and just just go right over and for
those who aren't familiar it means white
left it's their word for sjw but no no
no if the U.S uses this economic
conflict this trade War the economic war
or even the cold war or the hot War
whatever it becomes
they're not going to live anywhere near
as good as the people of China will live
so we can say like oh we'll send them to
China well I mean Chinese cities they
have political problems there's
authoritarianism but the people still
live in City conditions if we if we go
to war and we lose that war it's like
then you live at the whims of your of
your uh uh oh I see what you're saying
right yeah they're going to be living
like pows they're going to be right so
you know you're you're you know your
your ability to protest that's gone out
the window right you're you're your blog
your your social media accounts your
tumblers your whatever it is where
you're going the reason I mentioned
Tumblr is because that's you know it's
it's oh it's like over sharing right
it's over free it's it's who can say the
most taboo thing who can push the most
buttons that's gone that's going
overnight they're gonna you're gonna
start to make people support the CCP
they're going to have these I love it
there's this meme where these leftists
I'll tell you what they think about
Christianity next no yeah there's this
meme where the leftists like the Bernie
people are like we should put the one
percent in gulags make them break rocks
for a few months so they know what hard
work is like it's like bro you guys
don't do Hardware like I I I think if
what they don't realize is that the
things they're advocating for would put
them in gulags breaking Rock so they can
learn the value of hard work they're not
going to go to the guy who's like a
steep working at a steel mill not going
to go to the guy who's a construction
worker there's gonna keep working and
they're gonna be like okay they're gonna
go to the Intelligentsia the College
academic kids these activists and
they're going to be they're the problem
when whenever these takeovers happen
they immediately try and Purge the
intelligent Intelligentsia who made the
Revolution 100 yeah those people are
dangerous they're subversive right right
there's a reason that we don't talk
about dementia base anymore yeah yeah
everyone knows what happens to the bench
fix so but but ultimately I bring this
up because it's like if if war is
inevitable our greatest weakness is our
internal conflict I mean there are
already people who have been super
chatting us saying things like they
think China it's China's plan to promote
this these leftists anti-American ideas
sure to to teach not anti-American
history lessons to claim the country is
awful what happens then if there's
completely complete demoralization and
then a you know a Chinese boat crashes
on the shores of Santa Monica and a
bunch of soldiers walk out and they're
like we're here to liberate you from the
oppressive racist white people uh Paul
wolfowitz right we'll be greeted as
Liberator exactly here's the thing
though when we sort of talked about this
the other day
the people
bow to the Chinese government aren't
really the people who would have been
much of a threat had they put up a fight
anyway
what's the name of the Chinese Army
no no the official name what is it the
people's Liberation Army you see there
there are they've already thought of
this they've already thought this
through but if if we get to the point
where you know we're all racing our
embassies fly the flags of black lives
matter we're seeing children's show fly
the red salute the the CCP members
perform the red salute when they're you
know being brought into the party or
whatever oh yeah they're going to come
here and be like no no
we agree with you we're the same they're
going to be like they're going to have
the flags with the fist on it and then
the leftists are going to be like oh
this is a good thing and they're gonna
say we're here to liberate you from the
evil white supremacists and you're gonna
have a lot of people being like awesome
and then the Chinese Communist party
will go through everything from social
media you've ever posted including all
the people that they think are on their
side look at all there if there's one
thing that got set out
it's it's not even that they'd look
they'd look at it and say who's useful
and who's not yeah right if you're if
you're of no use to us if you if you
can't be put to work if you can't if
you're not in stem fields or producing
something of value if you're not an
actual worker then then you're just get
out of here you're done get get go go
sit and be you know go assume your
consumption bubble sit in your pod eat
your bugs right you know that's that's
you that's your job well so this goes
back to the conversation we were talking
about before let me pull up this story I
find very very strange and what it's
about the pods basically from from
Business Insider most Millennial
homeowners regret buying their home
survey funds that just reeks of me of
propaganda yeah you don't want to own
your own home right where you're paying
less than you would for a rent and
you're keeping all the equity except for
the interest no no you don't want to do
that it's a terrible thing does it does
it say why does it say like Millennials
want to move around more or is does he
even give anything they say 20 said uh
expensive maintenance costs and 13 said
it was because they overpaid and I look
at that and I'm like this article to me
reeks of live in the Pod we've already
got all the eat the bugs articles the
cicadas by the way the cicadas are
getting smaller so I went outside today
and that's because the big ones are
getting eaten well no no I think it's
because a big ones the strong ones came
out earlier and then died and what's
happening now is the weaker ones have
have been slow to emerge and they're
much smaller so we're close to the end
of the cicada swarm but the media has
been saying eat the bugs like crazy even
Tucker Carlson is like I'm gonna eat a
bug live on TV it's delicious
pastry on TV the only one you think you
shouldn't eat bugs
of course
of course you can of course actually
the the the the best Tucker is is using
actually at the end of a sentence yeah
that is very and then when when he has a
guest on that's a voice note he just
goes
Seamus wants you to think that you're
not supposed to eat bugs actually you
are actually
but actually people around the world eat
bugs and they enjoy it
uh so what about Lobster people eat that
your Lobster our Lobster is a bug
Lobster crap that's right bugs
[Laughter]
they had a whole like co-op with food
and everything so yeah no bugs
you should do a video spoof with uh
shots of antifa and do like the Earth to
stop documentary right the young Auntie
that's exactly approaches the female and
performs his dance amazing ritual it
doesn't work anyway anyway we're talking
about eating the bugs and then we'll
have the Snoop Dogg version on top of
that yeah I got some questions about
this article well so so it's it's an
article it's not the only one right
there's also this other story from
Reuters that says U.S consumer sour on
housing markets buying conditions I mean
I guess that's true because the ultra
wealthy are buying up these houses but
bro they're saying live in the pot and
eat the bugs the people who don't buy
houses have you seen apartments in New
York they are pods dude I remember
watching these these stories on like the
news or they're like this apartment goes
for three thousand dollars it's a closet
yeah it's literally a closet and they're
like it's a bed in it I mean I mean Hong
Kong is basically like that you know
they got these really tiny cramped
Apartments there's there's like a
subreddit dedicated for these really
awful tiny Apartments where it's like a
bed next to to a toilet in a closet well
there's there's even worse if if you
look at some of the illegal housing
structure they have set up in Hong Kong
and Beijing where it'll be these sort of
like large kind of kind of like room
ruin right now but inside the room
they'll have essentially what looks like
uh steel rack bunk beds and then you can
rent one of the bunks and you might be
in a room with like 80 other dudes and
you know here's a family that's got like
two bunks right but it's like five
people and that's it and you go to work
and you come back to your bunk and it's
I like the Pod would be like a step up
from some of that stuff wow yeah oh yeah
well that's where we're going
um so I I think it's time and we'll love
it you will own nothing and you'll be
happy they make that video but you know
what they're not wrong
they're not wrong
people can look this is what I was
outstanders earlier today if you were
born in the 1400s
are you going to complain about not
having a smartphone you wouldn't know
what Smartphone is are you guys
complaining about not being able to
teleport right now no yes well yeah all
the time sometimes yeah do you have any
idea how long it takes me to drive here
yeah
teleporting just kills you and recreates
you in another place that's true so is
it real is it really you yeah is it
really you yeah well so so look right
now there's a bunch of Technology
that'll exist in 100 years we don't know
about right and we don't have access to
it I mean we're we're relatively happy
that's what it is so they so this is
what they're exploiting they're
exploiting that if if the if the serfs
have access to knowledge then they will
become unhappy with their circumstances
so they want us to be ignorant the
people who are following the mainstream
media not watching shows like this not
getting a critical uh thought process
through they're just gonna Brian Selter
said it so it must be true I'm happy
they're gonna get their home taken away
from some ridiculous they're saying oh
no because of covet we've got to take
your house now and they're gonna go well
if it saves One Life that'll be it and
then people who aren't in those States
and red States this is this is what's
crazy
the right states are going the direction
DeSantis Abbott no vaccine passports New
York California Illinois Washington yes
so what happens New York says if you
want to go to these businesses you need
to vaccine The Excelsior pass they call
it so what happens if you're visiting
from Texas just a tourist you want to go
visit sorry can't come in we don't like
your kind around here yeah so people
won't go
what will happen is people who live in
New York who don't want to live under a
vaccine passport in a pod or eating bugs
we'll move to Texas Texas will then
become ideologically homogeneous among
people who like Freedom don't want to
live in pods or eat bugs ooh I don't
know about that man because I think a
lot of people will leave these blue
States for a red state but still vote
for all the horrible things that
destroyed their state in the first place
they'll go like oh I really don't like
all of these things the government's
forcing me to do so I'm going to move
somewhere where I'm more free but then
they're just going to vote for all the
same stupid stuff that destroyed their
place I don't think so because the
reason I disagree with that is the
people in blue States who are former
vaccine passports are happy with them
and demanding them they're they're these
Tick Tock videos where the girls like I
can't believe our governor just ban
vaccine passports like how Dom they're
not they don't want to live there they
want to leave and people in New York are
like why don't we have more what what
advice.com right they wrote this other
this article the other day why aren't we
mandating vaccine passports these people
are going to jump and cheer to be in New
York getting locked down under these
things and every and and people who
don't like that will leave not wanting
to live that way and then you will have
an actual physical divide between states
rights and ideology and then it's like
the politicians from Washington and the
politicians from you know Utah or
whatever or whoever else passed the
abandoned vaccine passports they are
going to be like totally different
countries no shared culture completely
at odds and then what happens what
happens when New York says you get Cuomo
being like we have to have vaccine
passports because of the the potential
for a fifth wave and then he says we're
gonna have to lock down the borders like
we did last time and do checks for
people who are vaccinated when the
pandemic first started they had cops at
the at the roads into it out of
Manhattan that's already started to an
extent with this this and I think they
keep changing the name of the Indian
variant or The Nepalese variant they
keep but there there's already people
saying that we're not sure if the
current vaccines that have been rolled
out will be effective against the new
variant which is always sort of like one
of the corollaries with the vaccine
right that hey this may not affect new
variants well it looks like the thing
that's that's actually spreading across
India and is now you know particularly
continuing may not be affected by the
curve so effective yet so what happens
then if you live in Texas or Florida or
North Carolina is is a is an East Coast
State it voted for Trump and they have a
substantially lower uh ratio of
vaccinations what happens if you live
there and you're you try to go to New
York they're not gonna let you in
they're literally going to borrow and be
like ah if you're not vaccinated you
can't come no no then you'll have but
yeah you say oh no for sure no but the
seriousness is a hard divide it's a very
different issue than just like you know
you see it with gun owners right now so
they have the they have like the
drive-through laws that you like I if I
am a gun owner but I'm driving through a
state like New Jersey or I'm driving
through New York well as long as I'm not
stopping and you know spending
substantial amount of time in that state
then I can still have my guns in the car
I'm just driving through right this is
my my final destination as long as you
you know you're following you know
that'd be broken apart and ammo has to
be separate Etc et cetera but you can
physically have them this is different
because it's I will not go to that state
number one or I do not want people from
that state coming here number two and
that's only going to lead I mean uh
sports teams but you know what happens
with sports teams then do they still
play right are we gonna is that gonna be
allowed Etc what happens when a Texas
based sports team I'm sure which has
many conservatives playing on the team
you don't hear their politics and
they're like you know I talked to my
doctor vaccine's not right for me I
don't feel like doing it then they're
like well if you want to go play at the
World Series or whatever or the against
the Yankees in New York you have to
otherwise you can't go in and they're
back nah
there this is a hard divide so a lot of
people talked about is the Olympics
right now by the way is very endless
that's why you know we we were supposed
to be like gearing up for okay we had
the 2020 Olympics postponed to 2021 uh
Summer started you know where's the
Olympics like where's the gear up
towards it and in Tokyo they're freaking
out the the I was one IRC guy just
committed suicide just threw himself
Subway it's horrible because the the
sheer amount of pressure that's on them
because of all this and all these
athletes and you know you look at some
of these Sports by the way where you
know like a lot of them they they live
off of the Olympics right you can't the
whole sport collapses without that you
know that Olympics held every four years
um and so you know you realize that all
of these questions are having very real
consequences now right now in real time
and are we going to get to a situation
where I mean I think I think you know
you think of like like the late night
comedy oh those people in Texas they
won't come up you know imagine in how
insufferable Jimmy Kimmel is going right
once that starts but imagine then how
radical so if Jimmy Kimmel's the Leading
Edge of it right then how radical will
the even the more radical people become
towards people from you know somebody
walking down the street with a you know
a cowboy hat on does you do you become a
Target now yeah yeah I I so uh Bill
Maher said a while ago we're going to
tone down the attacks against Trump and
his supporters because it could very
well lead to a civil war Bill Maher
actually said that on the show I didn't
really say that that's great yes that's
it for him uh later on with you he said
there can't be a civil war because the
Mason-Dixon Line would go through Nana's
Kitchen or something like that which is
like a really dumb statement it's it's
like it's like he thinks time stopped
the moment he said those words bro the
future is a thing and things can change
does he think that like in 1861 they're
like there can't possibly be a civil war
yeah a lot of people thought that
exactly so it's like who do you think
you are you have no idea what could
happen we got all these counties in
Oregon just voted to secede from the
state and join Idaho they literally
voted to do that now whether or not
it'll happen probably not but the
sentiment is there now you have through
obviously there's cultural issues but
ultimately it comes out of tribal issues
for tribal reasons people are choosing
to do things like David Hogg I'm gonna
wear a mask so that no one thinks I'm a
Conservative Republican yeah it's
nothing to do with the CDC guidelines
there was a we had Elijah Shaffer on the
show the other
and and now he's flying back out he has
his tweet it's fantastic he said they
made an announcement over the over the
uh intercom on the on the plane that
even though the CDC changed the
guidelines on masks the the federal
government is still requiring everybody
abide by this which leaves all of these
people on the plane confused because
they were supposed to do what the CDC
said now they're being told they can't
so anyway I digress on that point
about listening to the science right
right so I bring that up because it is
totally tribal and now we are getting
the physical dividing line between the
tribes well have you ever heard real
quick like when your tribe expands and
contracts well just one more Point
there's a story from NPR that shows
if you if you look at all of the states
on a scale of the highest per capita
vaccinations to the lowest there's a
line right through the middle and
there's like a weird Gap all of the
states that are higher in in per capita
vaccinations who did they vote for
in 2020 I have no idea
and on the other side
they're already except for the four
states that were contested by Trump and
his team and I think Missouri I'm not
sure Missouri was contested but that
that makes sense you know it's wing
state all the trumps right all the Trump
supporting states are lower lower on the
vaccination per capita and the states
that were like really close and were
being contested are also slightly lower
and then all the hard blue Pro Biden
States totally like High 70 75
vaccinations so Washington they're now
rolling out vaccine passports in New
York we're going to see it everywhere
but what's happening is it's not a
hardcore thing where they're like you
know California isn't coming out and
saying You must have a vaccine passport
or else they're saying ah yes come in
and if you're not vaccinated you can go
into the bathroom and sit down and have
your beer but you can't be near other
people they're making people not
participate socially which creates not a
mandate but a social pressure toward
these things which means like I
mentioned people who live in New York
won't live that way will go to Florida
or Texas I know how many people do you
guys know move to Texas recently oh
we had some guests here and I'm not
going to say with the X I don't know if
they've announced their mode in Texas
but they're like yeah I'm moving to
Texas and I'm like a couple people yeah
several people and Florida Luke who was
on this show for two months Luger
casting rear change look what are you
doing you traitor he went to Florida
yeah I moved to the South about six
years ago oh how was it went down there
for school and never left so I don't
know anyone who's moving to Texas
because I'm already in the South you
know there's nowhere to go DeSantis is
doing a pretty good job not perfect but
nobody is and he's doing a probably one
of the best jobs in the country as a
governor in my opinion and so people
want to be there but I don't like living
in like people need to understand the
humidity oh in Florida is so intense
you're swimming you're like it's you
basically just Trump left
he's like I'm not I'm not doing this
what he's going back to New York he went
back to New York for the summer he said
I'm not I'm not even gonna be here
he's up in yeah
he did they said he did but I think
Ivanka did it publicly so I took a
picture she did it publicly but then but
then Trump you know they said he was
vaccinated and Melania before they left
the White House but they you know they
never really made a big public staying
out of it what about Baron a lot of
people do
um I don't know yeah yeah no idea he's
not in the at-risk category I wonder if
Trump would do that I just think you
know when New York they've announced
this massive I think it's like a 17
million dollar expansion they're funding
The Excelsior system it's more than just
vaccines The Excelsior system is going
to track your medical history period and
your age and a bunch of other things
which means they could actually say like
you can't be over 55 to come in here
scan your Excelsior pass they're like
they're really getting into this so let
me go back to what I was going to say
earlier is that you know
people are generally tribal right you
know that's that's how Humanity
developed you know where these bands of
tribes and then as As Cities and then
city-states started to become more
developed
um your your tribe expanded right and so
if you look into I think we're all
generally Millennials slash Elder
Millennials no he's uh I'm kind of I'm
right on the bridge of millennial and
gen Z okay what year were you born uh
95. oh wow
I might be I don't know I've heard
different definitions
yeah but anyway put it this way so if
you look at like 80s 90s you're a
millennial right okay your your sorry
your tribe was you was generally pretty
much the United States of America right
you know I'm an American first and then
you're everything else right you're then
you have your religion and then your
state and then what sports team you like
etc etc and then you know the enemy is
the Soviets or you know then eventually
it became you know the terrorists you
have to say it like that
you know really starting past 2008 and
you know I don't make this an Obama
thing but like I think it's a word
Financial as well that with that
Financial instability that you saw a
breakup of that idea and so because in
in times of uh scarcity right the tribes
get smaller and you're because we're
looking now we're thinking instead of
these these abundant uh you know this
idea that oh the future's always going
to be great we're looking to the next
Frontier we're sending space shuttles up
all the time right you know that's my
childhood now I take my kids to Cape
Canaveral the space shuttles are in
museums and Elon Musk and Bezos are like
doing something but we're not really
sure if it's real or not you know yeah
it doesn't it doesn't feel the same or
it doesn't have that same sort of
national uh ethos behind it the same way
the space shuttle program did and and
there's this question of like what team
am I on or some people question are you
the left or the right you know I don't
even remember anyone talking like that
when I was younger it's like yeah you
know I voted for Democrat I voted for
Republican this time because because I
like this team better I like this
political form better but there wasn't
this idea that you know you had to be on
one side all the time 24 7. and and so
the question you know really
psychologically speaking is is that
something that's Downstream of Economics
uh the same way that you know we say
politics exception from culture but it's
culture Downstream from economics yeah I
mean it's obviously all really
intermingled but there's something
interesting there about resources
Contracting and then people really
wanting to almost oust people from their
side it's almost like this biological
response there's less for all of us so
we need to find a reason to expel people
so that there's more for me it is
fascinating and I think ironically
enough that actually exacerbates the
problem too because the less people are
working together the less able they are
to build up the economic resources that
would allow for them to not have to oust
people you know it's historically part
of what would get people asked to do is
getting sick illness communicable Jesus
you know you get you throw them out of
the castle five-year-old has symptoms
throw them out yeah wait wait even if
it's your sister's son or whatever we
need only look at the chicken society
when a chicken gets sick or is hobbled
or weak they go nuts they attack it
they'll kill it no it's it's really
interesting though because something I
just said a moment ago I I um I want to
walk back a little bit or at least
expand upon because I mentioned that
when you start ousting people or purging
them from your group people aren't
working together so you're less likely
to develop the economic prosperity
that would be necessary for people to
live in harmony harmony but I wonder if
that's a correction mechanism because
it's very much possible and I would say
probably a concrete fact that once
people are really economically
prosperous they become much less
selective about the kind of behavior
that they're willing to tolerate we see
this in very developed countries the
moral fabric tends to begin to dissipate
and so maybe hard Economic Times are a
correction mechanism for that and people
sort of returning to a structure where
they are more selective about the kind
of behavior they'll tolerate because it
can't continue forever without anyone
doing whatever they want or else the
entire system gets destroyed fourth
earning
it was bad morals that got us into this
economic we're turning place it seems
like something really weird happened in
the past five years with a dramatic
cultural shift and it's funny left we
bring it up from time to time but left
and right are meaningless at this point
you know sort of I mean sure we use them
as tribal signifiers for the most part I
think I've said this before I do think
that
the left in many ways are descendants
of the initial left when I just look at
this main common threat from the left at
the time of the French Revolution when
the term was first coined has always
existed to oppose the Catholic church
and its values and battle against
tradition
and that's still true today of the left
but there's there's this really strange
shift that happened uh so just before
the show uh I played the song Hit That
by The Offspring and I'm like if you
listen to those lyrics sounds like a
very conservative song it's talking
about the consequences of of hookup
culture and I'm like if you wrote an
article right now no no joke take The
Offspring punk band a pop punk
mainstream whatever but this is 2003
take that song Take the lyrics and turn
it into an article so when they say like
you know the consequences are life away
you can say like your work work imagine
putting into like a relationship article
yeah well you'd be called far right yeah
be called far right yeah criticizing
Tinder and hook up culture and
misogynist the yep
uh you know backward toxic clearly you
know anti-female uh self-hatred it was
written by a female law you know she's
internalized patriarchy pure toxic
Purity culture one of my favorite punk
rock songs is why don't you get a job I
know I know it's pop punk it's not like
yeah so you know I was I thought about
this before I tweeted about it several
months ago but I was thinking about
again about how do we get how what
happened you know what happened did
Trump like take a sledgehammer to the
system the Multiverse shatter and
different realities merged and just like
nothing makes sense technological I'm
I'm racking my brain for what changed
technologically six seven years ago it's
the streaming capability that's
something what were you gonna say well
so no um so you know that whole bit of a
sort of you know everybody under 40
knows that this all started with harambe
but we're not sure why
right you know but I actually I was
talking to a friend of mine recently
um who shall remain nameless but he
actually had a good answer for why we
all sort of agree that it's harambe and
what you know he looked at harambe as a
symbol of society is just subtly out to
get you and they will just kill you for
no reason that even though not not to
get into whether or not harambe should
have been killed but uh you know because
the kid in there and all but that just
sort of the larger meta narrative that's
going on there that you could be hanging
out one day and that's in that Society
will just come and boom like a meat
cleaver I I hear the theory I respect it
but I think the more obvious theory is
just that harambe was an
interdimensional Time Lord who was
holding together the the No No for the
members thing you're going to get it
what do you what are you doing you're
gonna shut down completely over here the
uh the guy who killed harambe was like a
secret agent sent from like another
dimension and like you know he walks in
terms takes his glasses off the kid was
trying to protect yeah yeah like a
future leader I don't know I've actually
Associated a really good one a really
good meme of this recently this is a
quick child you need to under you need
to understand Dr fauci is improving
experiments with with the Wuhan
Institute of you've got to
warning which brings us to our next
story actually thank you harambe for the
Segway House Republicans demand answers
about why Facebook's censored lab leak
theories after it emerged that Mark
Zuckerberg was emailing Dr Anthony fauci
look man uh-oh do we have a conspiracy
fact at some point that is I saw a
really funny meme from somebody where it
show it was like 20 it was like 2018 and
it was like conspiracy theorists and
it's picture of the guy like all crazy
and then the next picture says it says
2021 conspiracy analyst he's wearing a
suit and glasses respectable looking
because okay so now what do we have
behind the scenes fouchy and big Tack
and these Labs we're all saying things
they were saying the opposite of
publicly like at a certain point is
there at least can we call it on a scale
of one to ten with one being like the
least and 10 being the worst it's a
level one conspiracy like not a whole
lot going on I'm not gonna pretend it's
the apocalypse but certainly Mark
Zuckerberg was colluding with Dr fauci
to censor factual information right
that's surreptitious that's unethical
that's amoral happening behind the
scenes between powerful interests to
suppress the public Tim that's been
debunked no it's been rebound no it's
been it's been rebug
if there is one thing I learned over the
past five or so years
it's that something can very quickly go
from conspiracy theory to fact I mean if
you asked me at the beginning of Trump's
Administration if the Deep state would
attempt to unseat a democratically
elected leader I'd be like that come on
that's crazy talk and then if you ask me
if there was an international Global
pedophile who had ties to virtually
every politician in the country or a
large number of them I'd be like that
seems a little bit out there and then
and then if you told me the guards would
fabricate you know records and fall
asleep or whatever and then he would die
in this jail cell I'd be like get out of
here dude
you want to know what's really funny uh
that one that one I'm like that's have
you ever been around the federal
government before I I do want to say one
point just don't forget what you're
gonna say uh we shouldn't okay we got to
call it when you when you put up the
theory you're bunking and then the
journalists will try to debunk and then
after they're proven wrong it's
rebunking rebunking yeah but no that on
top of everything that's just going on
with these leaks
and all of the information about the
pandemic we were told was just
conspiracy theory uh much of which
turned out to be true it just seems to
me that the difference between a
conspiracy theory and a fact is like
three months to a year conspiracy
analyst yeah and I'm not big I'm not big
into conservations either by any means
they're really you know but it's just
disturbing to see so many things that I
would have Shrugged off years ago is
insane nonsense being proven totally
correct well so I you know a lot of this
you know I think comes down for a lot of
people it's pattern recognition right so
I remember those initial task force
meetings that you know Fati was airing
and sometimes pens to be leading it
sometimes Trump would be there and it
would you know get into a huge
um you know combativeness with the media
and they would be asking them all sorts
of author questions Etc et cetera but I
actually would pay attention to fauci
and Berks who was like totally gone now
um when they were talking about they
said why is you know why is it that
covid-19 spread so quickly and you
remember we were always told it's it's
the spike proteins and The ace2
receptors and it's it's the ability of
the spike proteins to affect these H2
receptors and human lungs and that's it
just they fit so perfectly and that's
why it's able to spread so well in
humans right that was that was you get
the droplets on you and that's yeah
droplets I was trying to do that without
saying the word droplets and
um so that but that's that's you're
hearing this all the time and I said oh
that's that's interesting that's that's
very good I'm going to write that down
right
um and and then when the Wuhan lab
started coming up we started looking
into this they took down their database
very quickly but we were able to find
archived copies of this now in some of
it I'm reading it in Mandarin some of it
we're able to translate
um but when you're looking at some of
the actual
tests and research that was done and has
been published in the literature you say
well okay what what you know what is
gain of function research the heck
decide a year ago I couldn't tell you
what that meant right maybe even two
years ago
um
and you say well they were trying to
they modified mice to give them this
ace2 receptor in their lungs and then
they were using gain of function
research with to essentially speed up
the development of these coronaviruses
that they had you know collected from
this mine and abandoned mine or cave
system in quinbing area that had Spike
proteins to it so that they would have
Spike proteins and I would said huh
wasn't that the same thing that the guy
was talking about before with the two
and you know right this is me just
complete Layman here but these are the
same two terms that I just heard from
the task force meeting so that's what's
going on that was the Wuhan lab doing
that right okay so now let's uh let's
debunk something of our own here well
actually look credit goes to Daily Mail
no bats or pangolins were sold at Wuhan
wet markets immediately before covid-19
pandemic started Oxford study says
research looked at 50 000 animals traded
in Wuhan from 2017 to November 2019.
scientists found no evidence of bats or
pangolins kept in markets in the city
but they say other animals traded could
have easily spread coven 19. okay well
then the wet Market bat thing debunked
right yeah well according to them yeah
there you go well so I I read that
article I shared it today I shared the
study and but as a guy who had spent a
couple years living in China I'm
familiar with the wet markets it always
seemed completely insane to me that
people would eat food that came out of
these things
um bro have you seen gutter oil gutter
oil yes it's where they harvest used oil
from sewer lines filter out the garbage
and then boil it and use it for cooking
where do they do this in China
um I've probably had it I probably had
it there are times it's street food yeah
there are times where I'm eating street
food where they're like they're like hey
this is you know just I know you're
gonna lie when I ask you what kind of
meat this is so just don't even say
anything it's probably rad I don't know
but that's what people say like oh so
you know you've read dog man you've ever
had a dog like not not knowingly not
deliberately not intentionally not
intentionally certainly not
intentionally there was I remember there
was one place in Shanghai
um and a couple other guys I was over
with you know when I started out doing a
study abroad there and then I ended up
staying but there were a couple guys who
went in to say like hey yeah I had dog
right and it's like how was it he said
yeah it's kind of stringy I don't know
yeah um but anyway going back
how could you know
for the past three years exactly which
animals were in this wet market and
which ones were not right right how can
you really tell that there were no bats
or no pangolins at all in this market
that just to me that sounds like a
bridge too far and I know that it
certainly kind of fits in with what
everyone's been saying and I I think
there's actually a lot better evidence
to talk about for me the one I can't get
past in terms of lab League theory is
um how do you get a disease outbreak
that's directly related to uh bats or at
least bats with one
um what do they call a transmission
Vector animal in the middle
um without it affecting any local
populations that live in close proximity
to any of these things you're talking
about the middle of a downtown urban
center and I've read some of the you
know like the nature Journal articles
talking about this they say well you
know wuhan's in a it's in a it's in a
broad region like what do you mean it's
a broad region right every region is
Broad if your aperture is wide enough it
doesn't make any sense so this is a huge
Urban industrialized area like show me
the town where this broke out that's
near the bat caves that has the animals
right the zoonotic response like that's
what I'm waiting for that's what I'm
looking at let's talk about a crazy uh
I I hate the word conspiracy theory
because what I'm going to describe right
now is not a conspiracy in any sense of
the imagination what is it just that uh
it's obvious that there is a Surface
news world and a war like a governmental
news world meaning there's top secret
confidential secret information we don't
have access to so when currently right
yeah currently I mean it comes out
eventually or we we hope it does but
right now in the US government and the
Chinese government they are dealing with
a level of information that we can't see
so we're on the surface there you know I
I'm willing to bet that there's some
like NSA guy sitting in in his room
right now watching the show because he
loves it and and him and his buddies are
just like drinking and laughing being
like they're so wrong about all of this
China's on the moon and we've got you
know underwater bases and I'm not saying
it's actually that crazy having been in
that world you know I I I hate to say
that but like I can't I'm allowed to
confirm directly blah blah blah but it's
it's not
it's not that it's not that far removed
from reality
I'm just saying it's pretty close it's
very pretty close so when we're like oh
man you know the the air force moving
these planes there's somebody who's like
oh well actually we're doing this we're
not going to publicly say what we're
doing with our Air Force that's what
confused me about how they told us that
all the Air Force is now spread out
around the Pacific and that we're
re-diverting a Weaponry from Middle East
to China like why would we be told that
why would the world now be told all that
information well that's I mean well for
for a variety of reasons number one
number one though is show a force yeah
so you can't hide a B-52 bomber right
you can't hide an aircraft carrier so
that when you're talking about that's a
survivability operation so you're you're
separating your Force you can even see
this on a smaller scale where like uh
when the serious strikes were going on
or and then you know the U.S kind of
telegraphed that hey we're probably
gonna strike there you would see the
Syrian Air Force would they'd all take
off because they didn't know which base
was going to get hit but they knew it
was going to be one of them so uh part
of it it's it's it's sending a message
it's posturing a lot of this stuff gets
uh gets done on a very regular basis it
goes back to even the Clinton
Administration when when China
threatened Taiwan during some of their
first presidential elections or some of
the more contentious presidential
elections you know you would see this
but it it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's leading towards some kinetic action
Jack
you
you know things
are are rods from God real
defy I mean which which do we have
satellites loaded with tungsten rods to
draw the function rods yeah they call
them rods from God yeah yeah though that
one um no because I've heard that also
used with the uh like different types of
like directed energy
um it was in GI Joe the second one where
Cobra Commander takes control of the
satellite of course and then it drops a
Tungsten Rod which then slams into the
Earth and blows up London we have some
cool satellite stuff no not that I've
I've never seen anything like that but
we have some pretty cool satellite stuff
I'm waiting for that starlink so I
looked into it we're actually supposed
to any minute yeah because you're
because you're this would be an area
where yeah
every day too that'd be awesome can
someone call Elon and be like get these
guys started because I paid for it we're
on the waiting list so how does it work
yeah so people know what it is right
yeah yes it's it's high speed low
latency it was like gigabit internet for
satellite right and they send you a box
you just open the satellite thing plug
it in and you put it by the window I
guess I don't know so it's the idea of
satellite TV right but with your
internet connection yeah so the thing
about standard uh we have a satellite
internet backup system
for some reason didn't work the past few
days but it's like five megabits up so
it's really difficult to actually do a
broadcast
um but it works it'll be grainy low res
with starlink it would be broadcast
quality for like Pennies on the dollar
so this is what makes elon's styling so
competitive uh we're on the waiting list
so that from like right now until the
end of the year at any moment the Box
could arrive
I don't know if there's somebody you
know we can we call somebody and be like
hey you know just like look around the
place on the show come on you can you
can manipulate whatever you know crypto
you want to just let us know which one
to buy and you know give you give you
five minutes and you know I don't I
don't know if you smoke in here or not
like the Rogan uh family friendly family
friendly oh sorry sorry dude of course
we we'd love to have Elon on but like
I'll settle for getting a starlink so we
never lose internet again so we can do
the show that'd be cool if we did our
first starlink show with Elon oh that'd
be so fun yeah that'd be rad that's you
got to do so it's apparently sold out
now really yeah so in this area because
like we're kind of we're kind of in the
middle of nowhere it's like an hour and
a half from DC so it's like when you
look on the map it's just like you can't
really tell because DC's massive and
we're just like a tiny little blip away
but mountains trees it's like basically
West Virginia
just a bunch of you know Trump
supporting you know right-wing nut jobs
to live out here for the most part well
did you see that tweet from uh was
Virginia Heffernan from the LA times
earlier today talking about the uh the
gun ownership for the 50-mile radius no
so she was saying she was saying
um I I think I guess she was like buying
a house or just looking at this this
issue she was talking about she's
totally ridiculous she's the one who had
the the Trump supporting neighbor who
was shoveling her lawn and she was like
or shoving her driveway like I don't
know if I should thank him or what
should I say did he really shuffle my
driveway is the snow actually gone did
he shovel it out of hate I mean it was
white snow so you know and uh perhaps
he's building some sort of you know
Snowball so no she had a tweet up today
where she was saying in real estate
listings they should this is LA Times
columnist she's working right wired that
they should
um include how many people own guns
around you for a 50 mile radius and then
um you know correctly I'm getting any of
this wrong and then include a list of
all the mass shootings that have taken
place in conjunction now obviously
having a list of all the Gunners
completely illegal
um but also like there are websites you
can look at for criminal reports well no
that's that's that's what I was saying I
just I just quotes read it and I was
like yeah who wants to tell her because
yeah I'm willing to bet that in some of
the lowest crime radiuses of the United
States there's a ton of law-abiding gun
owners depends on the crime right so out
here there's a whole lot of drugs sure
right it's it's like I I'm guessing I'm
right between might be reading between
the lines I'm pretty sure she means
violent crime right right she actually
she actually says uh gun violence okay
she says gun violence in there yeah yeah
actually I'm pretty sure it's a lot
safer out here uh I'd be more worried
about Chicago uh yeah lots of gun laws
and lots of people shooting each other
let's see West Virginia's constitutional
carry and you know people like I don't I
hear gunshots all the time you know the
the other day yeah Baltimore's not that
far away though well so something I
explained a while ago it's when I live
in New York and I hear gunshots that
freaks me out right because you're not
supposed to also it's a really dense
urban area like what are they shooting
right out here it's like I wake up and
there's a gun I'm actually I wake up and
I'm kind of worried when there aren't
gunshots I'm like oh the neighbor's not
out something wrong yeah neighbors are
just you know I'm worried about their
neighbors man yes or yeah yeah one time
I think one of the neighbors came out
with his kids because it was just like
sounded like
it sounded full auto but it was just
like four people just shooting all at
the same time well that should be like
there's places in West Virginia where
you where you can do that
um uh some of the training I did uh when
I was still in the intelligence
Community we did out in a spot in West
Virginia that where they were able to
get uh get licenses and permits to shoot
we shot some pretty fun stuff oh yeah a
couple weeks ago yeah there's a range in
Georgia where you can shoot full auto
it's great really expensive but it's
great yeah there's a there's a thing to
do at uh the Defcon which is the hacker
convention where uh like in the early
days they go out into the Mojave and
they set up a bunch of guns and uh when
I went there several years ago that is
like eight years ago maybe now this guy
had a uh like belt fed 762 I think and
it was like you got to pay for the
rounds yourself and then have at it so
we had big boxes of you know belts and
it's like M24 I don't know what you're
going to work he had like three
different ones and they were just like
people were like
yeah it was it was it was that was
awesome yeah
yeah we did um we did that this place
down uh with actually Sinclair and we
were outside outside of Houston they
call it hella bacon
um where you can act you've you can
actually get permits to go up and do
this in a company that runs it it's
totally not a commercial etc etc but you
um so they do one range day where you
can just I mean anything you want to
shoot literally anything up to and
including a minigun RPG oh yeah you can
do an RPG no no no no no no no no come
on
um and then the next day you get up
super early in a helicopter they take
you up to shoot wild hogs yes with full
auto AR-15s and you're go you're flying
over the ranch and the ranch is one full
auto air 15s modified or what uh they're
modified it's like fire wow yeah it's
not just an M16 uh
um no no because they're still they're
still the compact they make all right
all right yeah a lot of people don't
understand how bad Hogs are it's it's
horrible so the ranchers want you up
there doing it right this this is an
invasive species they are pests uh they
tear it up they you know they kill um
they can go after you know livestock and
so but it's it's it's wild and people
don't realize the culture difference
because on your way to these ranches you
know you're you're flying there and
you're up in the air above you know I'm
looking down I'm like this there's a
talent right below me right you know and
no it's Texas so you know you pop off
there you're gonna start shooting back
this this is my thing on the great reset
I'm kind of like totally it's totally
different from the East Coast kind of
mentality if if uh if the great reset is
limited to if you if you live in big
cities you eat the bugs and live in the
Pod I'll be like okay like if you have a
choice to live in these awful places
sure whatever people can choose to do
that there are always going to be Hogs
to hunt it is impossible to get rid of
them it's impossible to get rid of them
basically everywhere where they exist
yeah we were up there for hours and they
just kept coming like we just had we
stopped because we were running we were
running along Fuel and we're like wow we
gotta flight out anybody who's familiar
with any kind of MMORPG knows that you
know there's Hogs they're just
respawning that's how you level up yeah
so I know so my level I mean I came in
pretty low like I was like this level
yeah as as much South Park got this
wrong you can't just kill Hogs boars to
level up because as soon as once you're
a few levels above them you stop getting
experience for doing it you were well
rested though so you got an XP bonus
well yeah exactly yeah that's right
eventually got to go for the most
dangerous group like the Boss Hog
we had Coyotes out there as well yeah
you know you know what they need wolves
we can find them the issue is that uh in
a lot of places with Wolves being
displaced because they were a threat to
us right right and so they fled then you
get invasive species running rampant
deer population explodes man people
don't understand why uh you hunt deer
and they're in like these cities are
true I'll put it this way I'd be willing
to bet let's do a study that if you went
to a city and asked this question okay
here's a question for you Jack you see a
butterfly caught in a spider's web do
you free it
me personally no why not
um because I know that that spider is
going to be there it's going to then
consume the butterfly and it's and all
those other pests and gnats and I don't
know if a spider would go after a cicada
but maybe right so so the idea is a
filtration system essentially right I'd
be willing to bet that if you go to a
city or if you go to like a liberal and
ask they'd free the butterfly whereas a
conservative wouldn't because obviously
we understand the beauty of the
butterfly I could be wrong I could be
totally wrong about this maybe Liberals
are just ruthless and they're like kill
them both or something crazy I don't
really think that I think they typically
would be like the butterflies an
important pollinator and it's beautiful
and a part of Nature and it shouldn't
die to a spider a spider can eat
anything else and so a lot of
conservatives would probably just be
alike circle of life you know that
spider eats the bugs eats the pest
butterfly or not so that's a difference
in mentality I think about you know so
we're city Folk out here we had a deer
feeder and they were like oh you're
gonna kill some deer and we're like nah
he's gonna feed them like why they're
pests no they're like they're awful is
that that's exactly what it was like
they overpopulate they destroy crops
they destroy trees they need to the
copulation levels need to be kept down
otherwise they get diseased and ridden
with like nasty parasites starved to
death and so they're like don't just
feed them and I'm like well the good
news is they don't like the deer feeder
the birds do like how the birds are fine
hey we had this growing up
um Valley Forge Park was always uh uh a
huge place for us to go on weekends
ended up actually got engaged got
married right right near there and
um but because it's Federal protected
it's Federal park right National Park
um the deer know this and so they know
if they go wrong they go in there right
well they know that like this is like
right so you get to the point where I
mean when it's dusk you you like can't
drive around right because the deer are
everywhere and they're tearing up all
this stuff and a lot of the land right
there that's that's actual you know some
of it it's it's some of these dirt Forts
and different fortifications that were
made by the actual uh continental army
they're under George Washington during
that winter
um right so Philadelphia has fallen the
British have taken it it's this is prior
to the uh uh the crossing of the
Delaware and the Battle of Trenton and
so or be just before that I should say
and so you know these deer are tearing
up actual U.S history but you know
people and this is Pennsylvania so
people are like so can can we go after
the deer please and and the federal
government had to do this whole like
permit system to let people go in and
then hire guys from like the USDA to
come in so there's actually like a deer
death squad basically wow I believe it's
under USDA from it's like years ago and
I'm like how do you they're walking
around up oh yeah which which department
are you with USDA you step aside
kid man I I uh I hope you're all sitting
down because it might infuriate you but
this morning I saw a deer and it was
eating our mulberries what it was eating
our moldings so what are guns for I know
that's right defending the Mulberry
Mulberry and I was shaking like [ __ ] kid
I killed Batman it was like I hear
mulberries are mine don't worry it was
Bambi's mom oh yeah yeah yeah it's like
that's like Simpsons uh don't don't let
their bovine nature fool you
given the chance a cow would kill you
and your dad
we have Papa trees out here do you guys
know what Papa's are
they're like I guess they're like mango
and banana combined oh yeah yeah it's
like the only uh that fruit of that type
in North America or something so we have
this tree and I remember seeing like the
deer were always crowding on our
driveway because there's a tree right
there and you know in August and
September whatever all these fruits are
there and they're like they're they're
in the middle of the road so no no for
real like when you're coming down at
night there's no street lights or
anything no no you got to be real
careful and then you see him standing
there really dumb yep they just like
they'll walk up to the car and just
stare at you as you're like heading like
what's this I'm like yeah like we talk
about Darwin Awards but no really
there's just too many of them we got
turkeys too we got a lot of turkeys yeah
I've seen them walking around in the
woods dude yeah yeah
they walk up kids are pushing you're
like
all right I'm straight I'm trying to get
back to the house I was unprepared for
how well you gobbled no but it's the
same thing when you when you talk to
people out here they're like turkeys huh
we can we can help you out with that and
I'm like what's the problem they're like
turkeys or pests like you got to get rid
of them they're like turkeys are bad
people too
then like there's like a video
turkeys are just spray painting and yeah
like it's like the beginning of one of
those cop shows and you see that yeah
yeah it's the turkeys of course it was
the turkeys he just like sniffed dude
Turkish someone saw a mountain lion out
here yeah really yeah like really really
yeah yeah which is I don't know why it's
rare it happens yeah but we were told
that on this side of the river because
because uh uh if you guys have ever
played any MMORPG you know that certain
Mobs Can Only spawn on certain sides of
the river like if you're in zones yeah
like if you're an Elwyn Forest you know
that the the boars and the Knolls don't
spawn in darkshire and the ghouls don't
spawn and Owen so uh across the river
from us there's like bears and it's like
way more serious because it's West
Virginia but in the Maryland side
they're like you don't gotta worry about
anything like deer it's like really low
level stuff but every so often a bear or
a bobcat or a mountain lion will be
spotted and so people were saying like
not too far from here in this area in
Western Maryland they spotted a like a
mountain lion or whatever so they're
like you got to be careful now think
about that you live out one of these
houses you get an alert you see on
Facebook like guys we got a report from
the local authorities there's a mountain
lion spotted in the area please be armed
and safe think about that please be
armed and safe yeah and now you get
these laws AR-15 come on man nobody
needed 15 you know 10 rounds and then
people are like if you can't hit it in
10 Rounds you shouldn't be shooting at
it oh okay so I'm not a professional I'm
not a professional military man or law
enforcement guy but I want to keep my
friends and family safe from a mountain
lion and if it takes me more look maybe
I'm really bad and I'm like trying to
protect myself from a mountain lion yeah
maybe maybe I need to have a standard
capacity magazine of 30 rounds if you're
not a marksman your whole family should
die if someone breaks in that's right
yeah a mountain lion breaks in given
that situation I mean you know I I I I I
have a military background but I'm I'm
never considered myself to be like you
know like there's certain I don't know
like as you come influencers pundits out
there that are like really focused on
Second Amendment and shooting and like
that's their whole thing I love them
they're great guys I I've always been
more like the current events breaking
news kind of guy but just to you know
defend the AR-15 for a second right that
you're talking about a Firearms platform
where
the reason so many people use it is
because it is versatile and because it
is something that has a great accuracy
for someone who is a hobbyist for
someone who is you know just getting
kind of getting into guns that you're
gonna have a better
um propensity for actually hitting your
target rather than you're using like
like a Glock or a 45 any nine millimeter
any handgun right certainly at a greater
distance right you are going to put your
rounds On Target in a safer more
controlled yeah
um situation with an AR-15 than you
would with almost any other firearm out
there speaking generally speaking think
about this you guys remember the story
about the guy who went to the Empire
State Building and then like it was like
a Revenge killing it it was a
disgruntled employee no so he goes to
the Empire State Building he's all angry
and then he takes a handgun and he
shoots a bunch of people he leaves the
building and the NYPD they run up to
stop him and they start firing wildly
hitting like seven oh yeah when was this
uh three years ago I think I totally
don't remember this it's kind of tragic
I think seven people got hit that's my
guess but I'm guessing it's seven people
other than the guy yeah they did 2012.
uh all Empire State shooting victims
were wounded by officers according to
police wow so uh on a busy Friday
morning let's pull this off let's let's
jump into this story
all right so this is CNN 2012 what month
uh August
and so they say I was in I was in
training for gitmo back then so I missed
a couple all Empire State shooting
victims were wounded by officers on a
busy Friday morning in Manhattan nine
pedestria nine pedestrians suffered
bullet or fragment wounds after police
Unleashed a hail of gunfired a man
walking with a 45 caliber pistol who had
just killed a former co-worker the
officers unloaded 16 rounds in the
shadow of the Empire State Building at a
disgruntled former apparel designer
killing him after he engaged in a gun
battle with police Authority said three
passerby sustained direct gunshot wounds
while the remaining six were hit by
fragments according to the New York
Police Commissioner Ray Kelly all
injuries were caused by police all
injuries were caused by police one
officer shot nine rounds and another
shot Seven please identified the gunman
as Jeffrey Johnson 58 who was apparently
laid off from his job as a designer of
women's accessories at hazan import Co
last year Johnson served in the U.S
Coast Guard in the mid 70s had two
rounds left in his pistol it holds eight
Kelly said now I just want to point
something out what do you think would
have happened if those officers had
rifles
AR-15s
I mean you can never say right but if
they're going at range and this guy's
moving if he's you know if he's being
furtive he's if he's trying to you know
use cover and concealment
they would have had a better just just
talking based on the numbers they would
have had a better chance of hitting him
directly and let's not even say a 556.
let's say the police were given a short
barrel nine millimeter worth of stock
like come on man you know I understand
we want to want the cops to be arms
armed these guys oh well they would say
militarization is police right right
um exactly that would be the reason so
they're saying the cops we you know a
Glock 17 or whatever and these cops Miss
it's not an easy thing to do they
complain about police and police
brutality it's like okay then give them
a a short-barreled rifle or AR pistol
with with us with a stock and they will
be way more accurate they will that one
shot fired guys down stop stop the
murder or dead in his tracks as he
started shooting at cops less bullets
fired more accurate this is a good
example of like we were saying that
that's exactly what I'm talking about
yeah it's not just the idea of
militarization of police it's the idea
of AR-15s are dangerous it's like dude
people who with handguns like handguns
I'll admit I mean maybe it's just me but
rifle's way easier I go to the range and
I can hit everything with the with the
with the AR-15 well you've got a long
gun you've got a longer Barrel so and
stabilize it it's more stable it's it's
more
um you know it's more forgiving
basically for those little mistakes with
you know a four inch barrel on a handgun
right you got to be front sight focused
you got to be dead on you have to have
your T all the way across real quick
that's what people don't understand is
that they assume an AR-15 is firing 556.
it's like you get get a nine millimeter
rifle yeah there are different variants
yeah or or 45 subsonics lower and more
accurate also I mean the vast majority
of gun violence is committed well the
vast majority of gun violence is
committed with handguns oh yeah all
rifles combined including the AR-15 kill
fewer people every year than hammers do
yeah oh I think sharks too incredibly
rare I don't know about sharks
yeah that's that's the thing and this is
what that judge actually in California
recently who struck down the um the
Firearms ban the assault quote unquote
assault weapons yeah which it's funny
because like I'll go to like you know
any uh any gun store online you type in
assault weapon they won't tell you I
don't sell defense weapons it's weird
I walked into a store and I was like
hello sir I would like to buy one
assault weapon and the man said that's
not that one please one assault weapon
one weapon for assault they're like
leaves right now the words the words
you're saying don't right so the judge
the judge in this case and that you know
if you I haven't gone through the whole
thing it's it's really long uh opinion
that he wrote that he put down but the
the uh the first part of it which was
driving you know sort of like the
anti-gun types nuts he said it's called
like a Swiss army knife and he said it's
like a Swiss army knife because it's
there when you need it and it solves so
many different uh different situations
different problems different challenges
that arise and the vast majority if this
is like this is the most popular gun in
the United States the vast majority of
people who use this never use it to make
to commit a crime they are lawful they
are law-abiding they're using it safely
for lawful legal purposes this is
exactly what I've been trying to tell
people about my Barrett M82 you know
like what happens if like I don't know
an international band of terrorists that
like yeah exactly like the Fast and
Furious cure they're fighting and then I
see this helicopter and I'm like look I
gotta protect my property from this
International cabal led by Charlize
throne and so I've got a 50 BMG you
never know what I mean she's not gonna
be able to hit you from the helicopter I
I do love this though because like we
posted the Vlog where I have the the
Barrett I mean it's a 50 BMG and we were
shooting it at a plate or whatever and
then these lefties are like what are you
going to hunt with that and I was like
what does hunting have to do with
anything yeah hunting yeah but for half
a second I thought you said plane it's
like two plates
we were hoping that it would vaporize
the target
like it would because the steel plate
was rated for 308 and we're like if we
hit this it's probably gonna blow up we
uh one one person Dan got got a grant a
glancing shot so it just dented it but
it was also on a wooden you know it was
mounted so it absorbed a lot of the hit
there's some places to go where I've
done and this in West Virginia where
they'll let you do like abandoned cars
oh that was like the glass in and
everything yeah we had like a BMW and a
Mercedes and we were like take that one
percent
class class War I also got two at one
point with one of these things and they
just buy these junk cars for you to be
able to use and for tactical training
um they had they actually got one of the
trainings we went through was firing a
firing handgun from the driver's seat
through the windshield at a Target oh
and so yeah so learning how the
difference or the angle of the
windshield versus if you know your
target so okay your Target's here so you
want to shoot Center Mass but because of
the angle of deflection you actually
want to kind of fire down in a sense and
it bends it up so that it bends
that's crazy it was awesome it was it
was it was just amazing I always tell
people behind the engine block right
yeah you know so you could do these
tests where they they'll have the car
that was um in the George Floyd square
that was when when the shooting broke
out you can actually hear and I'm
guessing it's some security who's there
with like it was like some British or
you know foreign
um reporter and he doesn't know what to
do and here's this guy just go get
behind the engine block go go and that's
yeah don't don't hide behind the doors
and don't ever do that in in the movies
the cops are literally behind the door
and I'm like dude that's like a
millimeter of like well some some police
cars will have we'll have some armor
there but yeah just just don't assume
your car isn't up armored you know if
God forbid you're ever in that situation
yeah engine block all day long however I
don't know if you guys wanted to get
into this the engine block is also what
allows for pit Maneuvers to take place
that uh oh that video that came out so
it's the same way idea because yes the
engine block is this large chunk of
metal right that's right in the front of
the car but that's also what leaves a
car's weight balance completely off
right so your trunks never going to have
more weight than the engine block
there's this video that's going viral
where a cop is trying to pull over this
woman for some like minor traffic
violations
so he decides to murder her to just
straight up kill the woman what so I'm
I'm being a bit hyperbolic he performs a
pit maneuver and flips her vehicle over
and crashes it and then he walks over
and she's like help and he's like
pulling her out of the overturned
vehicles
I wouldn't even describe it like that
it's it's he so she clearly slow like
she speed I would say she's speeding
right because I watched the whole video
I mean she definitely looks like she's
speeding um I can't see any of the other
cars on the road so you don't know if
she's like going up much faster than
everybody else she's clearly going to
faster conditions
um so he goes to floor puts a blinkers
on on so
but then there's no like shoulder right
there's no safe spot for her to get off
so she puts her turn signal on as if
she's looking for an exit but no exit
appears so she slows down and there's a
very noticeable change in her rate of
speed at this point in the video
um and she puts her emergency emergency
lights on right like hey I understand
like she's clearly signaling to the
officer that you know I acknowledge that
you were behind me that you have your
lights on and she's like
just looking for somewhere to do that
safely
um which you would think and
he decides to write this up as if she's
fleeing and says like hey I've got a
fleeing suspect I'm within my rights
here I'm going to execute a pit maneuver
so for people who don't know pit
maneuver is when you you use that again
as I was talking about that weight in
that imbalance that exists in all cars
that you know except for the you could
still do it but the ones that don't have
um some cars have the engine in the rear
some Volkswagens used to have that
Teslas yeah
um yeah you wouldn't be able to do it so
you know another reason to have Elon
Musk on
um and so you you use that weight of
your engine block to essentially smack
the back of the of another car and have
it spin out of control nothing in the
proper setting the car is just supposed
to spin around so that you don't uh so
that it can't travel forward and then it
stops the vehicle it's not forward
progress what happens here is he
attempts a pit maneuver while the car is
already close to the shoulder right so I
that's one of those like a Derek chovin
thing we're like is that how they teach
you to do right a pit maneuver because
where's the car going to spin it's
obviously going to smack into the
shoulder which it does then crosses the
lanes hits the other shoulder head on
the car flips the SUV flips over it's
already a lot of weight imbalance issues
and inherent SUVs uh he's driving H2 for
this this Pro this radio station I
worked for and it was like the worst
possible thing to ever drive in right I
can imagine any conditions and this
thing is like wobbling all over like
never the death traps absolutely death
traps but hey billboard on Wheels right
and so he gets out of the car and he's
like strolling up to this thing where
the heck you know and it's one of those
look I you know I I don't know what he
was thinking I don't want to describe
intention based off of video but looks
bad looks looks really bad looks really
bad that he does not seem he does not
seem very you know uh worried that you
know he's just flipped a car over and
potentially somebody could be injured
dead or anything and in I'm certainly
I'm sure this will come up in the the
case but he also doesn't seem to
perceive a threat because he doesn't and
I go back and watch the video he doesn't
appear to have his gun drawn and he's
you know he's not thinking like oh this
is some hardened criminal that you know
I have to be worried about so his gun's
not drawn he's not approaching uh
stealthily or anything like that he's
just sort of
like it's the weirdest thing he's just
walking it's like he's in shock like he
thinks he killed somebody no he seems
like indifferent I yeah I would I don't
even see that and again you know that's
that's me looking at a couple seconds of
video I can't I can't tell I'm not going
to try to mind read it looked like
that's fair the cop was in the right
lane but he had to exit so she sped up
to pass him to get into the right lane
to exit rather than slow down to get
behind him to exit like that's an
awkward situation where you need to exit
and someone's on your right and you got
either I don't think there's an exit at
all in the video I don't think there's
any exit that comes up like there's
nowhere for her to go basically yeah
anyway and it's one of those ones where
it's like
at that point but if that were me
um and I know that there's a cop behind
me with his lights on I would just pull
it over in the shoulder if I really if I
really couldn't find anywhere because I
know that you know other cars are going
to see that and I'm not getting out of
my car anyway so if he like really wants
me to pull over and there legitimately
isn't anywhere to go I would just pull
over shoulder yeah yeah I would well how
about we take super chats everybody if
you have not already and you like the
show you got to smash that like button
uh it really does help subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you think it's important in the
conversations we have are important and
go to timcast.com become a member we'll
have a bonus segment coming up we
usually put them up around 11 p.m and
maybe you've noticed we we publish them
immediately so that as soon as the video
is done in coding after it's uploaded
you'll be able to watch it but that
means if you get there too early it's
like you're watching the encoder process
it's better than us sitting around like
just not publishing it for an hour and
then you have to wait a longer amount of
time but hey it is what it is go to
timcast.com sign up really excited for
The Newsroom and some of the people
we're bringing on we're going to have
more consistent merch we're going to be
expanding everything's gonna be
fantastic we want to do many
documentaries and we just need to get
the leadership staff who are going to be
able to handle that it's not it's not
easy
let's read some of these super chats and
don't forget smash that like button
smash it all right uh hung drizzts with
the most true and correct Super Chat
ever he said Tim pool is the greatest
artist of Our Generation seriously
though can't wait until blue cities
excuse me excuse me I'm gonna let you
finish but Freedom Tunes is the greatest
artistic Endeavor of all time excuse me
no no uh hungred says Tim pool is the
greatest artist and he is the greatest
he's the best everyone knows
fake news and then hung dritz comes out
and says I take it back no he's dumb
he's the worst
uh he says I can't wait follow up Super
Chat not yeah JK that's how we get
people to just keep giving more money
yeah frankly I think he's actually awful
he was the worst no one agrees yeah if
you guys won we would do whole Super
Chat threads where we'll argue with you
keep super chatting troll yourself Keep
It Coming fast guys can we get up to 7
000 likes because it's 6.2 right now
that's all I'm asking can we get the ten
thousand can we get the ten thousand can
we get 10.50
also youtube.com Freedom Tunes guys it's
actually yes it's Sheamus's birthday
it's so at some point this year it is
yeah
so if you all hit that like button just
for me
when I was born that reminds me of the
Rick and Morty thing where he's like
what does he ask him what's nine times
eight and he's like at least 42. you're
that's exactly right it is at least
something like that all right uh hungry
says can't wait until the blue cities
feel the economic burden from
ostracization of unvaxed
fuzzy bunny says sch55 have you seen
that viral video where the woman gets a
scam call and she answers it like a
robot thank you for calling eBay
customer service it's her it was so good
because she's like to continue press 55
and then you hear like the actually hit
fit five five
it's great
and then it shows you guys remember 55
from group x no come on you know that
there's
55.50
yes
that's why Sheamus makes funny videos
I barely remember that video I just
remember it was like some I just
remember like a little anime I just want
bang bang oh my gosh I remember that
part I can't recommend it it's bad all
right all right let's uh let's we got
I'll fight you naked says what what
excuse me
letter to a woke heart says has anyone
at timcast read it it's short anybody
read letter to a welcome negative who
wrote that I don't know I look it up
Andy Stone says Ben Lee the trucker says
hi hi Ben's my friend hey there you go
reality hijacks as poso when are you
gonna tell Bannon to come to the mansion
and do a podcast that was the same
question I got last time you know he's
he's up in New York right now he um he
ended up not even coming back to DC so
he's stuck in New York and he won't he
literally will not leave this hotel I
have his mug you have his mug I somehow
ended up with literally his mug that's
amazing someone who knew him took it
from his house or something and then
like someone else was hanging out with
him and then got it he did big deal
though huge deal first haircut he's
gotten in like two years so he just just
it's not yeah it's not if you're
watching the show it's not uh it doesn't
have a pack that's an actual haircut so
kudos to him all right let's read some
more we got uh Anthony Campo says Biden
is bought by China with him as Perez
going to war with them makes no sense it
costs Millions for rallies that Trump is
about to do makes me think who is really
uh makes me think who really is in
charge Tim foil hat please yes say Tim
foil hat Nicholas hooker says did you
see Ashley bevitt's family is suing to
release the identity of the officer who
killed her also vote
for NJ governor oh
I I think I did hear that that was a
little while ago right the family was
suing yeah I I think that the um yeah I
know there's a lot of speculation over
you know is it this officer is that
officer I I have to imagine in that
lawsuit that name's gonna come out
yeah I hope so Jason Q2 says Big Ups to
cast Castle entertaining for sure seeing
the pad hoping members events showcase
Tim's Speakeasy and casino gaming
operation in the basement of secret
bunker we shall persevere we actually
have a poker table Yeah but it's like
it's the gaming table so I feel like
we're playing Magic or a board game
you've got like it's a it's a cushion on
the edge and you could have a cup holder
but I also think you know we'll play
little fun silly poker games and like we
have tokens for the slot machine in the
arcade so you can like win that stuff
listen Sky Madison never tells anybody
where the game's gonna be with the
action's always here and the action's
always here in the temple house this
thing I just want to mention something
we're up to 7.7 K likes that's great but
it is not we agree too ladies and
Gentlemen let's get 10 000 likes on this
video it is Sheamus's birthday at some
point this year it's gonna be my
birthday you know what you know what I'm
even more proud of
not quite but very proud of the video
that Tim and I just released were Tim
voices Dr fauci it was hysterical we
almost cried laughing recording
we were crying laughing Lydia was there
were there any specific words that um
that came up like anyone
I were crying laughing and also
um for people who support the show at
patreon.com Freedom Tunes you can watch
the behind the scenes of us recording
yeah we use this setup right here to do
the vo because like after the show
finished I was like oh Sheamus do you
have that that video you want me to read
so we just turned the camera on and
filmed it and you can hear Sheamus being
like say it like this say it like this
and I'm like okay and then I redo it the
whole thing is great because it's like
it's like the uh it's like a kid and
he's breaking up with Dr Fati as if like
I don't want you in my life anymore and
he's like if you break up with me your
grandmother will die
you're always hyperbolic don't don't
give too much of it away you guys
we won't give away we won't give away
oh yeah we we literally improved a
sequel right after we recorded it and we
honestly think that was even funnier
like this one's really funny but like
that is funny yeah we I think we were
like really crying laughing yeah it was
so old
we were just like coming up with
everything on the spot it was and then
as as we were walking away Shannon's
like no I gotta record one more thing
and he runs back and starts recording
again I did yeah
like what if Trump said this and then
Tim came back then I'll say this yeah it
was very organic it was great well we'll
see we'll see the the sequel comes out
all right let's see uh David Maki says
UAP Tech can be built in a garage prove
it to yourself you can make a capacitor
Thruster out of a s i slash graphene
wafer and a laser mirror based on
quantized inertia Theory and the mick
Becker and Bot capacitor Thruster
experience EXP
I have no idea what Ian well what are
you using the laser for to move it
around I don't know I don't know um
silicon graphene wafer sounds cool
though should we build a surface a surf
like like a like a like a hovercraft
where we can fly yes yes
because we can build I don't want to
call qualified yes I don't want to build
a quadcopter have you seen the the
flying motorcycle where it's just two
big fans and yeah the problem is
controlling left and right is difficult
that's why people like doing quad but
maybe you could do two small Jets on the
side kind of like how the flight suits
work so they're not for a lift they're
for stabilization right and then you
just have the two big in the front and
you could you know ride it around maybe
we just built like with the Hobgoblin
head or the Green Goblin and Spiderman
yeah yes yeah we'll just build that and
we'll fly around yeah and then Ian you
can work on the on the pumpkin bombs but
we're a family-friendly show so it'll
just be like whipped cream comes out
sure yeah it's tasty and you can throw
cupcakes at people instead that's great
I'll toss them underhand yeah that's
good yeah that'll be over at cast Castle
uh this past weekend I went hunting for
cicadas I have a a a gun that shoots
salt for bugs and so I was actually
catching the cicadas and then you know I
was hunting as a kid you really got into
it he had like the paint on and yeah I
was hiding I was in a deer blind waiting
for the cicada to come out it's like a
belt of cicada heads and then and then
he saw cicada in front of him but then
one
the bug thing it doesn't actually hurt
the cicadas it just stuns them it
doesn't even it just makes them angrier
dude and then they come after you don't
want an angry cicade on your hands dude
there's screams
yeah that's true One landed on me and I
was like poking him to get him off and
he was just sitting there and I poke him
oh my God it's terrifying so the Lively
ones are loud and you get a lot of them
together a whole swarm you'll go by like
a tree you know I try to do um like a
bike ride with my kid once a day and
we'll go we'll go under the tree and
it's just like
dude and I saw it was so brutal because
uh someone here collected a bunch of a
bunch of
um cicadas in a jar to feed to the
chickens and they just got thrown into
the little chicken area
the chicken City and they're just laying
on the ground like like screaming and
the chickens are just massacring them
like one chicken is like picking up a
cicada like shaking it around as it's
screaming I was like I'm like you know
this is why I don't feel bad when I eat
chicken at all yes wow what's that
what's that uh what's that account
nature is brutal
somebody somebody mentioned in the chat
that I'm building a zeppelin uh that's
that is true and correct the the so if
you don't know the story for like years
Wikipedia had a section where it claimed
I invented a zeppelin for live streaming
which I never did and so it finally got
removed because they were like what's
the source for it's like one article
from the guardian so then I was like
just to make a point I'm now going to
actually do it yes and invent it so they
have to put it back
I'm going to retroactively make a fake
article true and then they can like put
it back living up to the hype what will
they do they're like this article was
fake When It Was Written but then he
eventually did do this so do we use this
article you will create like a like a
disclaimer Paradox where the disclaimer
for the original article that they will
have run they'll need to also disclaim
but in the context of a large like it'll
just be an entire story but actually now
it's true because he decided to help us
this is like what the Beatles used to do
with um with the Paul is dead stuff do
you guys know about that oh yeah so it
it started as you know as just sort of
this this thing that a bunch of like
hippie kids at some U.S college had
gotten into they thought they were
secret messages in the Beatles yeah if
you play it back Paul is a dead man I
miss him instead this is this but then
the Beatles found out about it and they
were like oh this is the coolest thing
so they actually started planting secret
messages in their songs
and you know if you play something
backwards and John Lennon was super big
into this that and it was sort of like
it you know it's is it art imitating
reality kind of thing and it just became
this whole you know big deal where all
of the secret messages we could put in
but I always I always thought it was
that's actually the the story that got
me into the Beatles that like wow these
guys thought it was so cool that they
actually took it to the next level and
started doing it because hey that's fun
yeah all right we got uh quiet guitarist
fan says World economic Forum you will
own nothing and you will be happy Neo I
need guns lots of guns uh guns are good
Investments yeah functional devices the
storm properly came clean they don't
lose their value visual economic Forum
not only has me blocked on Twitter but
they they called me out by name uh the
other day over some and you're you're
blocked by them and unblocked but
they're calling me out as this like wow
you know this this known purveyor of
whatever
um it had to do with the the um the
macaron emails from 2017 which were
completely True by the way like that was
an actual legit League that we found but
they just labeled disinformation but
isn't that hilarious how you'll find
people's actual actual emails and
they'll be like that's not true that's
disinformation yeah dude I I'm like
browsing Reddit there's if you look at
the front page of all the leftists how
they talk about fauci's emails they've
they have no idea what they're talking
about yeah they've literally not read
any of them don't understand the context
and they're like there was like one
email where he said not to wear masks it
was exactly in line with what he was
saying publicly and I'm like well that's
true but the real issue is that there
were scientists saying early on I
thought it was engineered fauci ended up
giving these guys grants at some point
what the guy was saying publicly
literally the same day was the exact
opposite of what he was telling future
like there's a lot of stuff in there
right so what that that's a type of I
mean it's a cope right but you know the
the type of logical fallacy that because
it's a false because right so I've
created instead of having to actually
think through like me possibly being
wrong on something I can just allow the
cognitive dissonance to take over and
the false because will be a shortcut
across that to say well okay there was
this one but it wasn't a big deal here's
why it wasn't a big deal and therefore
the re you know therefore because of
that all of it is not a big deal well
that's a false because because that only
pertains to one all right Stoli Clark
says
Tim I'm challenging you and Ian to a
game of two-headed giant Commander also
everyone regardless of your opinion you
need to you need you need to prepare for
some crazy times and why don't you
people ever talk about xrp I don't know
a lot about xrp but what I can say is
anyone who plays me and e in a game of
two-headed giant Commander would regret
it yeah you'd get messed up you get
messed up bad I don't know about that I
think Jack and I could beat you the the
the level of the Decks that Ian and I
have are so high we don't like playing
each other anymore because it's like
turn one wins it's just insane it's like
oh wow he got the Mana Crypt he wins
let's just play a new game okay Zoom
well who goes first you win you win good
I've got a Kiki geeky deck it's just
absolutely Bonkers I've got uh narset's
crazy but that's more about like just
locking the board down and being silly
but urza's just yeah I think if we did
urza and maybe thasa that's just dude
stop Town Rashad and foot pay with fossa
and it's like I win everyone sacrifice
all your permanents I win I'll counter
everything they try to do to stop you
from winning well if you have urgent all
of your board on the table then maybe
the foot pad won't get to you two out of
giants is the best ah we'd wipe the
floor with whoever dared challenge us
that's it no I think we would win
me and Jack against you too we're doing
Sheamus is gonna be like I'll play the
lone War elf and then Ian's like I'll
drop my whole board with urza and I win
the game I actually don't know anything
about this game I'm just talking
Smackdown because I know I don't know
either
any opportunity to argue the best uh
I'll take it one of the best card games
ever made I'm like how does this pertain
to the rosary yeah exactly yeah
June is the month of the Sacred Heart of
Jesus that's right it is no it actually
is I love this conspiracy theory uh the
physicality Channel says do we have any
proof this is actually live
uh
uh yes well they just asked that
question and you read it out loud I
assume they asked it yeah wouldn't that
be true
is it the Super Chat itself proof it's
live I guess they think we get super
chats sent to us in advance we read
people's well now it's proven for them
but I guess for everybody else yeah I
don't know it's 9 48 p.m yeah it took
the time and they're like you timed that
perfect time exactly that you knew keep
sending super chats and you'll find out
yeah yeah we should you know what I'm
gonna do I want to design a clock that
it'll be like your standard you know
what's a clock called that's just like a
center clock because it's like a digital
numerical analog analog clock but I want
to have it so that like every every five
minutes the arms randomly pull to a
different position dude right what if
there was a clock that no matter when
you look at you it always showed you
what time it was now so like if there's
a if the clock was on video and recorded
you look at it now and it would show
now's time even though what I don't know
some new technology Ian what are you
talking about with
what's over here that would be a
multi-dimensional block because if if
Sheamus is watching and someone else is
watching it yeah
can someone who can build this Ian can
you build this a clock where instead of
actually telling time every five minutes
the arms randomly jump to a different
position yeah sure so then like during
the show The Arms will just be like
randomly like people are like what's
great what's going on like you already
set it on air that'd be so fantastic to
do it's just like the audience is like
what is going on this is not live how
can it be the clock is
well we'll we'll start thinking about
things like that maybe we can do like
wait I shouldn't say any more ideas okay
yeah right that's some fantastic ideas
that like if you ever say them on air
you'll ruin them like we should miss his
clothes
it comes back let's read some more
Unholy Prophet says I'm 30 and I own my
own house and my mom lives next door
it's like the show loves uh it's like
the show everyone loves Raymond there
you go and I bet she comes over when she
wants to borrow a cup of sugar
she and she calls you on holy prophet
Unholy you come over here and bring me a
cup of sugar I gotta say my mom just got
a place
um that's uh right down the street from
us and with with the kids it's it's
great I mean that's oh yeah that is sort
of the traditional you know
setup right so that it's it's
multi-generational families live closed
right you're not you're not just
shipping the you know Outsourcing your
child care to some stranger or yeah
exactly you know somebody found on
care.com it's it's great it's it's
grandparents it's amazing they love the
kids they know the kids it's it's theirs
right and it's I love it all right we
got uh Nova zero says antifa are pests
not bugs don't eat antifa no protein
whatsoever use pesticides like tear gas
and joy also have you seen how big
Australian bush roaches are I have not
I'm sure they're huge yeah antifa kind
of reminders if you ever remind me of
cicadas in in many many ways the screams
right so the screams is a big part of it
a chicken can defeat them the way the
chicken the the Swarms right the Swarms
that are absolutely and they are an
invasive species they think gender is a
social construct have you ever you ever
get along with a cicada dude their
political opinions are all the way right
and they will not stop talking about
them they just read all the time time
and for some reason they can just
automatically generate mulch of
cocktails yeah yes all right we got uh
Rob lerson says breaking JBS paid 11
million dollars in Bitcoin Ransom to
cyber criminals who last week knocked
out plants that processed one-fifth of
the nation's meat Supply Wall Street
Journal wow oh that's only going to get
worse yeah I think the thing that killed
me with the colonial pipeline was when
the CEO was testifying yesterday and
said and admitted that said well they
asked him and said and Senator Hawley I
think Senator Hawley actually asked him
why didn't you just go in manually and
turn on the pipeline you guys see this
one and he responded that well
essentially all the workers that know
how to operate the pipeline manually are
either retired or deceased at this point
oh my God I'm depressing we actually
didn't have the capability of operating
it manually anymore that's insane yeah
that's not good I would say so yeah I
would agree with you on that yeah all
right we got Chris Bali says Tim I keep
hearing you refer to NC as an East Coast
State well it is on the East Coast it is
a Southern state that is very
conservative most people here have
rejected covid measures FYI I just
referred you I refer to it as an East
Coast State because it's very easy to
get to North Carolina from North
Carolina to New York so if New York
implements all these restrictions
there's probably a lot of people in
North Carolina who are like driving up
to New York or even driving through New
York maybe you aren't going to vacation
or something it's not like you're in Los
Angeles yeah well there is kind of this
like
regionalization of the term East Coast
like you wouldn't consider Florida and
East Coast how dare you even though it
is I live in Georgia and I consider
myself a coastal the people wouldn't say
it right when they say East Coast they
kind of mean like Mid-Atlantic Northeast
yeah I get it I'm just making a
geographical reference because like yeah
admittedly was it like 16 hours New York
to Florida or something or is it 24 yes
it's not that bad no it's not 24. no
it's like 16 right yeah maybe 18. yeah
I've done I've done Florida to DC to
Florida yeah yeah
all right let's see
B13 Sr what is it Beezer I grew up on
Rage Against the Machine in today's kids
my nephews call me a conservative yeah
well to be fair Rage Against the Machine
today is rage on behalf of the machine
yeah that's right man isn't that isn't
that funny because I was the reason I
brought up The Offspring earlier about
hit that is because I was listening to
one of their latest songs and it's not
overt but it really does sound like
they're pro-establishment these days
maybe they always were I mean it's 2003
right or no no what year was why don't
you oh yeah hit that was 2003 well how
are we defining the machine
these this political establishment what
it's always been um against
oh yeah but they're Rage Against the
Machine that's what I'm saying they have
a video that was like directed by
Michael Moore yeah at one point with
rage and they're on Wall Street and
they're like protesting they protested
in front of the the DNC at one point
they went on Cuba I mean these guys were
pretty pretty you know populist Uprising
against quote unquote The Establishment
yeah we got uh Logan Culver says clearly
the culture shift happened when they
fired up the Large Hadron Collider in
2008 and ripped a hole in our time
continuum yes well you guys should watch
Loki because that's what it's all about
you know what you guys um you're up to
9.3 K likes not again and that's great
but we agreed to 20 000. oh I did that's
what I remember I said initially yeah
I said 20 000. I love you guys let's get
us there come on 20K likes and watch the
New Freedom tunes videos do both you can
do both and subscribe at Freedom Tunes
man all right all right Sonny James says
Sonny James says like they say politics
is religion for ugly people bio
surveillance like vaccine passports
forces the individual to buy technology
what better for disease capitalists than
data mining you to train robots half the
cost of immigrants the pitch is VR
wow
all right let's see Daniel Welch says is
the difference in States you describe
like Brave New World sterile and
dehumanized World State versus
degenerate Savage lands
I don't know yeah I think there's an
extent where Brave New World actually
came a little bit closer than Orwell and
I know that's sort of not the you know
not the the quote unquote you know
prevailing wisdom but when you look at
what Huxley proposed it was this world
Not only was it
um
Advanced Insurance technology but it was
instant gratification of anything you
wanted it was
um it was you know free love free sex
this is totally appreciated exactly like
the Counter Culture it's 1920s I believe
1925 he wrote that and so you know he
got a lot closer and then so they fly
over you know quote unquote the flyover
states but then you can go and they have
these little platforms where you can
land on and sort of look down to people
living in like what we consider the
Midwest now and that's like a vacation
to see how the how the Savages that they
call them the Savages live you know I
mean I completely agree with you it's
interesting he actually gets more into
the sexual politics which is a huge part
of why everything's falling apart oh
yeah I mean that's like half the book
all right the one free man says would
you die not for America as we know it
but for the America you know it could be
so for the Papal States of America
because it could be that and I would die
for that I've seen so many people die
futably that I I'm not really looking to
throw myself away yeah I guess that's a
complicated question I mean look that's
that's clearly a risk that my
grandfather was willing to take I think
I think in the Second World War I think
there's something Noble about that I'm
not a you know a big fan of the
industrial military complex or our
current foreign policy but if there was
a good reason to go to war I mean I'm
not going to sit here and say I'm so
brave and Macho I would absolutely go do
it but I definitely believe there are
reasons which weren't fighting I mean
I'll I'll I mean you know as as Patton
once said you know the object of warfare
is yes not to die for your country but
have the have the enemy die for his that
being said you know I know that I've I'm
not someone who currently and I said
this before argued that I don't think
that we are on a collision course with
China but that being said should the CCP
try uh trust me I I've been focused on
these guys solely for about 15 years
right now I would know how to tear them
apart Within less than 18 months don't
say that on air Disney will never hire
you now
hedge trimmer says the mother of all
short sells is upon us the eight Army
owns the float by 93 percent is that for
GameStop we'll see what happens that can
be big
was that isn't Apes AMC uh I don't know
it's just meme I thought
okay yeah meme cryptos
with this that'd be all meme stocks so
if you like if you guys like meme stocks
I did I did a video called game stunks
that you guys should also check out at
Freedom Tunes I really enjoy it yeah
all right
cleft the misfit says Tim I'm going to
keep posting this till you read it
please make a gorilla t-shirt in your
honor with a beanie and lettuce hands I
bought I bought AMC yeah I bought back
you're right you're back in yeah yeah
for a while now back on the train all
right I woke up and I was like I don't
even have anything to invest in I was
like AMC I guess yeah they're they're
people that are moving on if you click
on Wall Street bets AMC isn't even like
the hot thing right now anymore the
people have kind of moved on from it
this is a a hive you know it's a bees
but I haven't by the way and then I have
not it's a hive and what they've
realized is that when there's High short
interest in a stock it's guaranteed to
go up right just hedge funds are like
we're gonna tank the stock where I'll
make money they announce it then
everybody follows suit and they do the
opposite and they're guaranteed to sell
the stock at a higher price it's a win
it's just absolutely win so now the
whole the whole game is going to shift
yeah based on this new meta the firms
are going to stop doing that they should
have kept it low-key so they can keep
taking advantage of these firms when
they try to do it now that the word is
out they're just gonna know it's too big
of a risk to short yep
let's see
Jayvon Cronin says I love how Ian
randomly gets mad in the middle of a
sentence and chills out by the end
always catches me off guard dude I am
fire an electrical right that's so true
okay
um RAV4 says more people died in 2020
alone from shoving foreign objects in
their bums then people die from AR-15s
the past five years combined
well we should we should absolutely ban
did those things or are we are we
debunking or has that been bunked it is
being bunked now we can choose we can
choose to accept the bunk debunk and
then if we do debunk then the other
party has a chance to rebunk okay
yeah we should ban all those
all right let's see let's uh let's do a
couple more here
Ward spouse says no drinks in the damn
table ever a few hundreds of thousands
in cards I have stacks of Irreplaceable
cards I get it oh yeah we have like uh
I've got an alpha Bolt
I like that was that worth like a
thousand bucks these days oh man maybe I
don't know maybe not maybe not that much
but it was like it was like like 70
bucks and I bought it I think I'm gonna
look it up a while ago let's imagine if
somebody just like knocks over their
coffee or something
well it's it's sealed into special
things that sealed yeah but I do have
some cards that are worth like a lot
it's like one of one of my deck has some
like I probably shouldn't say too much
about the power of this deck but it's
got some really really old expensive
cards in it let's just say he had some
collateral for that AMC stock he bought
uh I went I went and I was like I'm
gonna leverage my magic the Gathering
deck and they were like whoa whoa he
went down to the bank they're like we
don't have a vault big enough safe
enough looks like the alpha lightning
Bolt's about 500 bucks now okay 500
bucks there you go wow
so apparently uh
the the magic the Gathering cards have
track higher uh have a higher rate of
return a percentage of return than like
the s p 500. it is raining wow yeah I
heard that right here yeah noise yeah
it's like in waves guess who gets to
drive home three thousands hey if the
power goes out it was nice doing the
show with you guys yeah we made it yeah
so let's just uh we'll do a couple more
so we can get to that bonus segment
Ian use your abilities to keep us online
you got it positive energy displacing
the clouds we do have the reserve
batteries Goblin hands says Tim as a
truck driver the truck driver shortage
is a myth they are pushing the
autonomous trucks in also the Chinese
owned the biggest pork company in the
U.S Smithfield if they decide they can
shut us down easily yeah wow
uh Jamie Cagney says how's your internet
today I have a star link set up to sell
you if you want check out the jobs email
can you write that down Jamie yeah yeah
yes 100 I don't can you do that because
we would absolutely love to get starlink
um we're on the waiting list so they
announced it's in our area we paid for
it they said now you just have to wait
first come first serve so it's like yo
Elon does anybody who's watching know
Elon be like yo hey Eli you send this
guy he's not gonna do a show he needs
starlink in the middle of nowhere I also
wonder can you move the starlink around
because if they just give it to you
can't just like take it and put it
somewhere else use it somewhere else all
right all right that storm is really
really bad so uh let's let's we'll wrap
things up make sure to follow us on
Facebook Facebook and Instagram timcast
IRL you can share our videos on Facebook
help help us grow the network and then
redirect people to timcast.com be a
member we're gonna have a a hoot of a
bonus segment coming up with all these
these crazy folks we got we got chilling
out here you can follow me personally at
timcast basically everywhere shows live
Monday through Friday share the show it
really does help Jack you want to shout
out anything uh yeah shout out to
humanevents.com we're taking to the CCP
on a daily basis as well as to the
corrupt leaders of the United States
government uh here today we're going
after the U.S military today a guy who
just said a lot of things that he
probably shouldn't have said so we've
scooped that and he had to delete his
Twitter account just before we came out
of this Battalion Commander uh and also
check out antifababook.com if you want
to learn the truth about this
organization never before published
information about conversations from FBI
director Ray directly with President
Trump no one's got this stuff we've got
it through our reporting check it out
antifa book.com I make cartoons I think
they're pretty good go watch the fauci
episode watch the fauci episode you guys
just got it it's actually pretty good
thank you you guys just got us to 10 000
likes it's half of what I asked for but
not least it's not what you guys
promised you promised twenty thousand so
here's how you can make it up to me I
want you to go over to youtube.com
freedomtunes we are at about 644 000
Subs I'm trying to get up to 650 000
subs and I'm also trying to get you guys
to watch our news
you gotta wear a mask because of the
droplets it was because I was such a
good director that I got the performance
of your life on
that too and so everyone should go watch
that youtube.com Freedom Tunes it's
called Dr fauci's emails it's very fun
we had a great time making it you will
all enjoy it go over there and sub I
love you sure yeah you can follow me
across crossland.net as well but hey
send me that positive energy send that
positive energy up into the skies above
us to to move those clouds like when oil
hits water and you just see it fly or
when water Hits Oil or something like
that hopefully do that before I have to
drive yeah do that so Jack it's an easy
ride home yeah seriously I have children
yes definitely Jack needs to get home in
one piece we want him to be safe it's
wild and crazy I have driven in some of
these storms eight both times I felt
kind of like I was gonna die I was with
Lauren Chen one day and I was with
Sheamus it's the next day and it was
freaking awful you can't see anything so
I'm hoping it's cleared out by then but
you guys can follow me on Twitter at
Sour Patch Lids I would like to have
more followers and Sour Patch Kids so
I'd really appreciate your help I
thought you're gonna say you wanted more
followers than Sheamus yes that's what
she does on Twitter
just pulling away though aren't they
they're What Sour Patch Kids is pulling
away I actually checked the other day
yeah you actually are quite close to
them I'm getting there all right
everybody make sure you go to
timcast.com for the bonus segment with
this crazy crew it'll be up hopefully
around 11 or so that's when we usually
put it up and we'll see you all then bye
guys